tu regardes on a de moins en moins de
monde regarde quand on a des occasions
ouais ça ne fait pas beaucoup ça c'est
11% de moins que la semaine dernière les
dents peut-être d'y revenir
t'as pas rester rester devant le poste
[Musique]
mystère
[Applaudissements]
c'est un ami cher ami
sur le plateau de tout le monde en parle
l'émission dont tout le monde parle avec
nous ce soir béatrice dalle
non
gina lollobrigida
jack lang
la maman de zacarias moussaoui
un retrait encore
l'auteur de la france qui tombe
[Applaudissements]
après l' omerta la vendetta médiatique
un peu
[Applaudissements]
monsieur ricard moine bouddhiste a
l'asb et la jet set
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nouvelle star mondiale du hip hop le
retour de kamel dans tout le monde en
rêve
le blind test de dj kost et
câble mon avis
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salon bien toi acadien très très bien
alors beaucoup de mails laurent dont le
teint de laurence d'ahnif trick de
hausse en hollande qui dit je constate
que ma fille aime peindre
alors je n'invite chez moi quand il veut
hollande car j'ai des portes et un bal
grand à repeindre
il est le bienvenu mais c'est moi qui
choisis la couleur simplement vous faire
un petit de vie ouais
et puis oui si c'est un chantier
intéressant on va partout en europe
aucun problème parlant toujours au sujet
du vert laurent il ya un garçon qui me
dit faut absolument une invit gilbert
montagné ce sera le seul appât
t'emmerder avec le vert il s'appelle
laurent doux et damien fabre est que
gilbert vient de se faire opérer il voit
très bien
gilbert et puis alors énorme de mails
sur mes coincoin quoi c'est vraiment
bravo gérard darmon je te remercie
maintenant je reçois une mayonnaise ça
va te marquer voilà donc on a acheté ça
on a un canard qui s'appelle john armand
voilà donc comment ça va bien boosté
l'ambiance beaucoup du mail
[Applaudissements]
mais vous avez vu que vous êtes là que
même les animaux en peluche s'attendait
donc beaucoup daily mail pour dire oh là
là pour ce cas l'un des joueurs
canadiens
voilà
je
[Applaudissements]
la bouche
soir antoine 6 ans qu'il vient
d'enclencher demander des tagueurs
d'égayer un petit peu le décor un boni
les bravos voilà vous avez faire quoi
ramzy on va faire un dirty musique
ouais je travaille sans échapper
d'amande ce soir donc mais on nous on
n'a jamais fait d'illégal à 1 et
pourquoi on est des vrais artistes
ah ben on va voir mettez vous au boulot
et puis là aussi sur les trucs ici un
bien est maintenant prise dalle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya une ébauche pas ouais c'est une
grosse mouche à merde là c'est la voie
non obama prenne la main comme le canard
un [ __ ]
ce qui ce quart à beth il va rester
parmi nos tu n'es pas assez rapides qui
assure le quart no non
london
voilà la mouche bleue
ça c'est de l'art moderne bon ouais chez
vous aussi pour 80000 euros vous pouvez
avoir ça bon je cherche
ouais repose en paix jeanine d'accord
non oui
béatrice dalle sera là dans trois
minutes qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
j'sais pas moi un peu on va chercher ce
que est ce que jean pierre dac une
invitée tiens ouais bah 13,2
[Musique]
bonsoir vous appelez comment béatrice
dalle béatrice dalle vous souvenez des
scènes de nu dans 37 2 le matin à temps
on va vous donner un micro béatrice
voilà tu lis pas bon soin ensuite
comment ça va direct le fion béatrice
quelle est votre actualité béatrice
comment ça va en ce moment
bienvenue ici kerry comment ça va on
sort en b atrous avait très bien bien et
dont lara jeune et en pleine lumière
[Applaudissements]
vous vous souvenez de scènes de nu dans
37 2 le matin béatrice la ouais c'était
très chaud j'en reviens toujours pas
vous n'êtes pas remis de sa non et c'est
vrai que depuis vous avez du mal à avoir
une sexualité épanouie parce que ça vous
à ça vous a profondément marqué
j'attends l'homme qui va me faire quoi
elle est mineure la 15 ans zac et là je
l'attends béatrice là j'ai 34 ans mais
avec zhu et ça se passe très bien ça se
passe bien avec nous et il est sympa oui
très poétique et c'est vrai qu'il a
mangé son singe non sisi d'ailleurs j'ai
goûté bas j'étais comme toi et début
j'avais envie de gerber mais après c'est
passé
je veux qu'on vienne un petit peu
béatrice sur ce problème de sexualité
qui a du mal à s'épanouir donc c'est
comment vous comptez faire pour ben je
sais pas j'ai demandé l'aide des
spécialistes mais bon je crois que mon
cas désespérés vous avez des sexologues
oui j'en ai vu un aux états unis
monsieur monsieur je suis plus quoi mais
d'où il va même du coin c'est tout ça ah
bon encore un type de film c'est
magnifique
oh c'est joli ce qu'ils font en vidant
nom n'en rajoute pas non plus d'hier
samedi c vhc berg et des beats on peut
le faire hein
vous vous savez dans ces n'ont pas trop
plu je suis vraiment fatigué et si on
était à la lumière qu'est-ce qui sait
danser la pop sur scène en avant en
avant sur scène allez tu me dises appelé
pendant mais une autre
là bas
m
chaque maman
là
les mots
charmant
[Musique]
première candidate max en place la 2e
qui s'y colle est ce que quelqu'un un
poème une récitation je voudrais qu'on
meubles vous savez que ça me faisait en
direct c'est pas très bon pour nous ils
vont tous se barrer sur la une
est ce que quelqu'un a une récitation
prend les baltringues mais c'est quoi ce
public soit je vais être obligé de
chanter la truite de schubert en
allemand laurent voilà spéciale dédicace
à maurice papon vas-y et aïn béni mathar
chanter ça donc j'ai vu dans l'immense
éternité bleutée des aigles de fer
oiseaux de l'enfer survolé aux armes
citoyens
foreman aux bataillons marchons vers
l'élimination de l'état nation voilà
[Applaudissements]
désigné béatrice dalle n'est toujours
pas prêt dont le rhénan désigner le
vainqueur de tout le monde en parle
academy alors oui oui
béatrice dalle non à craquer sa robe on
coud la robe béatrice dalle bien je vais
vous faire la truite de schubert
attention du silence s'il vous plaît
c'est pas facile
in einem bichon heil daschle aussi mme
frot heil d'ilahoun échauffourées
quelques erreurs qui ce que je leur dis
là où nichent au fort elles font reverdy
aval et jetant d'einstein
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
charles mouly et maintenant elle est
prête
j'accueille béatrice dalle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir dans le sol ce t-shirt vient
d'être recousu c'est ça ça peut te faire
du moins c'est parce qu'ils savent être
décousu béatrice ya pas de tee shirt
viendra kutcher et avec quoi nous nous
mais on n'avait pas prévenu que je me
suis déshabillé dernière minute la promo
télé c'est pénible pour toi ça dépend ça
dépend un qui savent à quoi hein
si je suis là c'est que ça va se barrer
tu vas bien alors béatrice dalle ont
fait vraie mission quoi pourquoi moi
béatrice dalle êtes à l'affiché du
nouveau film michael années que qui
s'appelle le temps du loup avec isabelle
huppert et patrice chéreau présenté hors
compétition au dernier festival de
cannes
car chéreau et en président du jury
voilà c'est pas possible
mais je pense que si ce film a été
présenté dans la compétition il aurait
eu la palme d'or aussi je suis sûr c'est
en plus un vrai film palmé d'or
alors moi je les ai vus mardi matin ce
film tout seul dans la salle mythique du
studio des ursulines et ça m'a fait un
super choc
pourquoi s'attacher aux vies comme ça
j'ai dire pourquoi je vais raconter
d'histoires c'est l'histoire d'une
famille européenne quelque part en
europe il ya le papa la maman le garçon
la fille et il arrive
un soir une nuit comme ça dans une
maison de campagne où il trouve une
famille de squatters qui occupent cette
maison et qui les prend en otage avant
d'abattre le père alors on pense
assister à un fait divers isolé et quand
isabelle huppert s'enfuit avec son fils
et sa fille c'est pour errer dans un
monde hostile et violent par exemple ils
vont chez un voisin à côté qui leur
claque la porte au nez
alors il marche comme ça dans la
campagne campagne qui était assez
familière parce que c'est des paysages
qu'on connaît mais très désolé jean chey
de cadavres peuplé de vagabond il arrive
dans une gare où il ya des trains qui
passent de temps en temps et en fait
c'est un camp de transit où vient
échouer une foule de réfugiés
alors on se demande ce qui s'est passé
pourquoi finalement le mot
dans cet état est ce qu'il ya eu une
guerre est ce qu'il ya eu la bombe
atomique est ce qu'il ya une catastrophe
écologique ou un krach économique en
fait on n'en sait rien du tout on sait
on sait pas géré pendant tout le film ce
qui s'est passé mais on sait que c'est
le chaos quoi voilà c'est un vrai
cauchemar
oui c'est ça voilà enfin des réponses
trop long mais non il aura bien le
concise
je vais ramasser alors les rapports
entre les gens sont très agressifs
chacun révèle sa vraie nature
et puis on comprend enfin moi c'est ce
que j'ai compris en tous les cas c'est
que années que dans ce film c'est le
monde d'aujourd'hui qui raconte en fait
absolument il ya des gens qui vivent
sans ce moment quoi c'est un manque
juste les rapports humains quand ça
devient difficile mais c'est leur
quotidien
ouais c'est très fort il s'appelle le
temps du loup de michael haneke marié
taux dé quoi je sais très bien qu'ils
sont pas faciles à reconnaître un temps
d 1
et comme il nous tient tous plus ou
moins sous sa coupe soit donc possible
qu'il fasse partie des juges excusez moi
mais qu'est ce que vous entendez par
juste
oui dit
oui
cher papa enfants que j'ai trouvé des
crayons du papier faut absolument que tu
écrives il se passe tant de choses et
enfin tuer la personne à qui parler
à bientôt j'espère et je sais pas si tu
peut désormais voir plus bas dans des
eaux lire ou entendre ceci nous situe
peut percevoir quoi que ce soit mais je
voudrais tellement y croire alors je
vais essayer tout simplement ont cherché
repas pas
vraiment difficile de trouver les mots
pour exprimer tout ça n'est pas fou des
autres quand on a aucune possibilité
d'en parler avec qui que ce soit je n'ai
relevé pour des cons et triple occasion
c'est vous qui parlez de compassion
excuse moi je peux pas me payer ce luxe
là c'est ta compassion avec une seule
frappe de ce temps dehors
voilà le temps du loup de michael haneke
avec célérité à patrice chéreau et
béatrice dalle qui est notre invité ce
soir
évidemment comme je disais avant la
bande-annonce est pas la catastrophe qui
est intéressante c'est le comportement
des gens quoi quand ils ont pu les
réflexes de la vie quotidienne comme
diane que quand l'eau ne coule plus du
robinet quoi quand vous avez une panne
d'électricité à paris vous êtes au bord
du suicide est commun des pays à côté
convient et les vrais rapports humains
sortent pas en bien ou en mal
alors vous êtes la femme de patrice
chéreau dans le film alors lui il essaye
de calmer le jeu 1 sans arrêt et vous
vous péter les plombs
il ya de quoi quand on voit ce qu'ils
sont en train de dire alors ce film nous
touche parce qu'évidemment les réfugiés
qu'on voit dans le film c'est pas des
réfugiés d'avancé pas de répit j'ai
d'ailleurs c'est nous on songe un peu à
la shoah quand même parce que ça se
passe beaucoup autour des tra donc il ya
une espèce de réminiscences comme ça des
déportations pendant la pause dans la
guerre sans souci un yougoslave y on a
une proche de nous ils sont comme nous
n'est pas préoccupé pendant pas mal de
temps c'est vrai il ya une phrase de
vous que j'adore des actrices dalle ces
jeux ne fait pas une carrière je vis
mais oui c'est comme les rôles de
composition je suis pas un enfant qu'on
déguise ça m'intéresse pas quoi je peux
donner qu'est-ce que j'ai donc si je
demande tend à metteur en scène qui me
blues chaque jour c'est parce que chaque
jour je lui ai donné ma vie sur le
tournage est donc voilà je sois indécent
de faire autrement en plus vous laisser
guider par votre instinct dans la vie
oui je trouve ça me réussit bien donc je
continue alors la semaine dernière avec
joey starr qui étaient là bas votre
instinct vous a pas trompés parce que
comme on l'a dit pendant cette émission
vous avez été parmi les premiers ou les
premières vous apercevoir en tous les
cas que c'était quelqu'un d'exceptionnel
aujourd'hui c'est à peu près communément
admis mais à l'époque c'était pas
évident mais écoutez je pense que voilà
on n'écoutait pas ce qu'ils disent et de
la poésie dès la première fois que j'ai
rencontré moi je les ai vus j'ai entendu
si sûr qu'il est pas né au xviiie siècle
dans une famille aristocrate weezy de
ses origines bolivien quoi mais on est
pétri de poing l'autre face de vous
j'aime bien c'est quand j'aime c'est à
en mourir mais je pense pas qu'on puisse
imposer sa déjà et je vois pas comment
on peut aimer autrement que par amour
vous seriez prête à enterrer le corps de
quelqu'un qui périt tué un enfant à vous
accrocher la drogue apparemment oui oui
d'accord on l'a bien fait d'accord ouais
vous faire tatouer la lettre d comme
didier le vrai nom de joe et vous seriez
prêtre c'est déjà fait ces eaux dans mon
dos et c'est lui qui commande à la
maison
nous on perd de son équipe ensemble à
une personne comme vous l'appelez vous
mon mari oui depuis
80 jeunes et lui vous appelle jean
claude n'ont pas tout le temps c'est
tout le temps en particulier quand c'est
qu'en ces jours de fête ils vous
appellent journée en battant 6 sur 17
mai comme ça on savait pas je sais pas
quand il me cherche et que comme les
gens savent qui je suis c'est est plus
discret de m'appeler jean-claude
d'accord mais vous deviez pas vous
marier cet été
ben tu vois pourquoi pas vous n'êtes pas
mariée finalement pourquoi vous n'êtes
pas mariée sérieux mais si tu regardes
pas pourquoi
ah oui ça me regarde pas le plein de
trucs qui me regardent pas ouais ouais
ouais c'est chiant il parlait aussi de
faire un enfant cet été mais ça peut te
[ __ ] aussi vous avez pas fait qu'est
ce que t'en sais vas-y vous avez fait je
me maquillais ce concert classique short
track
pourquoi est ce qu'on les fasse passer
un test en simple et en effet vous avez
déclaré moi j'aimais bien parce que vous
avez dit je me vois bien en mer en mère
autoritaire strictes comme toutes les
femmes qui ont été un peu trash avant
mais souvent on voit les gens qu'on peut
tout à fait vous êtes lettrage vous même
à peine vous avez pu crucifier là non
plus j'aime bien pourquoi parce que je
crois justement tellement jésus-christ
dans son message que j'ai pas envie de
porter à l'endroit où il est vrai je
trouve ça dur sata bien quoi vous
trouvez que l'instrument de torture
c'est pas vrai ouais et vous aimer jésus
quand même louis le message jésus-christ
mais pas comme quelque chose de mystique
comme moi ça m'intéresse si ses fils de
l'homme parce que je trouve très belle
est que deux mille ans après la mort à
la planète y croit si c'est le fils de
la reine c'est facile c'est moi ça me
fait croire en l'amour voilà c'est juste
le message d'amour et de tolérance parce
que si on a eu un comme ça il y en
ad'autres je crois juste en langue grâce
à lui à seulement cela vous applaudir
mais je vous a plu
[Applaudissements]
quelques similitudes entre jésus et joué
par certains côtés en tous les cas on
aime beaucoup joyce taille si on a passé
un très bon moment avec lui la semaine
dernière et hier vient quand il veut il
a eu sa carte de bons clients je crois
qu'il n'a pas de carte de bons clients
mais il a des dents en or et ça fait
peur il peut rentrer
alors qu'ils avaient d'ailleurs été pour
faire l'alliance qui l'a fait fondre des
noms comme pour qu'est-ce qui se
passerait si elle fait des boucles
d'oreilles avec les nombres de dio mais
tu vois ça vous va très bien alors comme
joey starr mais pas là ce soir peut pas
être là toutes les semaines non plus
hein c'est vous qui allez vous y coller
béatrice dalle va faire l'interview joey
starr
bonsoir joey vous avez pris des
pectoraux non on fait de la gym en ce
moment il est trop con ton truc je peux
pas je te jure je crois pas parce que je
suis je réponds non mais ça va
vas-y non non non je suis pas d'accord
je t'ai pas d'accord non bon reconnaît
bien là jo avait un temps fait d'accord
c'est bien de jouer tu veux quoi comme
interview je sais pas ce que tu fais
tout nu pas ça s'il te plaît ne l'a pas
philippe des to be free n'ont rien de
regarder
qu'est ce que tu veux mais qu'est ce que
t'es d'hôtes à proposer mais je sais pas
on peut faire une interview improvisée
non laurent parfait allez on fait
l'interview improvisé on rallume
attention interview improvisée
[Musique]
il a fallu improviser laurent béatrice
vous dites souvent que vous n'êtes pas
une actrice alors pourquoi faire ce
métier bordel
j'ai commencé à le dire tout à l'heure
je suis pas un enfant qu'on déguise un
jour on fait clochette un jour en
princesse je peux donner que ce que j'ai
donc quand je dis je suis pas une
actrice parce que pour moi le cinéma
c'est pas la fiction la fiction elle
commence le tournage s'arrête et que je
suis sur mon canapé sonic qui fait qu'on
ne considère jamais comme une actrice
bien compter sur un plateau à 8 heures
par jour mais encore cette force 25e
film we sont mes papiers d'identité
j'aime et je suis actrice au qui sont
violées c'est marrant tu verras pas
spontanément à toi tu irais béatrice est
vrai que vous allez plus jamais tourné
de cette mue
c'est pour ça vous fait tatouer pour pu
être obligés d'être nul non mais ça a
tellement été difficile en 37 2 je suis
quelqu'un de tellement tu dis que je
peux pas quoi j arrive pas non pour
toujours je sais pas faut vraiment que
il faudrait qu'il soit infiniment
justifié déjà dans la seine mais j'ai
trop de mal steven spielberg vous
demande de petit nul à dire je m'en fous
ouais dans 17 fois cécile cassard tête
en maillot de bain quand même web sites
imitant laurent pourquoi plutôt n'est
tenu par titre ascap s'avère c'est fini
tenue
béatrice est ce que on a attrapé les
cambrioleurs qui vous ont cambriolé
sinon ils ont pris quoi alors vous des
conneries en plus vous avez des gens que
je connais pas ce que vus ils ont ils
ont pris précisément des shows et rend
les affaires c'est pas drôle ça l'a fait
sans plus introduisez c'est bien plus
sérieusement béatrice et si vous pensez
pas que votre caractère très particulier
a nui à votre carrière
n'agit pas l'impression puisque je
trouve qu'avec des gens que j'ai super
envie je rêve d'un metteur en scène et
je travaille avec donc apparemment non
béatrice vous n'avez pas de frère est ce
que ça vous a manqué si je m'en suis
fait des frères personnellement moi les
liens de sang veulent pas dire grand
chose donc je me suis trouvé des frères
à partir de l'adresse que vous avez
présenté job à vos parents au moment où
est ce qu a dit ahmad déjeuner dominical
avec un gigot non non il n'a pas été
présenté en février une couleur qui pas
la motion
joey nous a parlé de sa maman la semaine
dernière avec qui il allait voir les
demoiselles de rochefort
sans doute est ce que est ce que vous la
connaissez la maman de joey oui vous
entendez bien avec elle
ouais c'est accepter oui je crois est ce
que vous mangez du singe mes
entraînements pourquoi pas l'hôtesse de
l'air
c'est super pas drôle c'est en plus
quand on connaît vraiment l'histoire
c'est tellement parce qu'elle dédie
alors béatrice dont tu n'es pas une
actrice
as tu des loisirs voilà
non c'est pour ça dans le film s'arrête
je m'emmerde je ne fais rien mais si
vous aussi vous voulez poser des
questions à béatrice dalle par sms
laurent vous avez des questions qui
arrivent les questions des
téléspectateurs n'ont pas de questions
les gens ont peur les gens sont sur le
qui vive
les gens sont tendus ils ont perdu
beaucoup plus c'est normal en même temps
vous savez que fumer tue b après oui je
suis écrite à la route il a décidé de
vous suicider
non mais je me dis avec ce que j'ai fait
dans ma vie c'est pas une fois qu'ils
vont me tuer et bah très bien l'état
merci beaucoup
en répondant seulement l etat ont valu
les gens qui pour sa très
professionnellement genre les gens ont
reconnu tout de suite
merci beaucoup les gens je dirais tout
simplement bien la regarde les tagueurs
ça se passe rien prévu samedi
voilà qu'est ce qu'ils étaient un masque
sa pure que toxiques aille bien
attention et maintenant démunis
ouais si gina lollobrigida
[Musique]
là
ça
[Musique]
et voilà dit non merci c'est pas la
vraie on nous dit jean ah ça c'est bien
passé le grand cabaret avec patrick
sébastien
très bien si cette partie avant la
chanson de la fin à ça décoiffe quand
même
gina lollobrigida vous avez vous êtes la
première femme dont j'ai été amoureux
vraiment vraiment je peux vous le dire
ce soir j'étais fou d'amour pour vous et
afu tellement amoureuse des mois à l'été
2011 à celle de l'amour c'était plus
proche de l'ani sma mais tu sais qu'à
l'époque à l'école rien bâtir
rien que de dire rien que de dire le nom
oui on sait qu'à gina lollobrigida quand
on disait lolo déterminer c'est déjà un
péché si j'ai un pc déjà répété votre
nom comme ça à l'école avait été
consacré d'ailleurs je t'ai pas le seul
être amoureux de vous la plus belle
femme du monde et vous avez été mon
fantasme et le fantasme millions
d'hommes
gina pendant pendant des années ça vous
le savez bien j'étais avant-hier ou là
je n'ai pas skié avant-hier alors aussi
les marbres la carrière est énorme
énorme au cinéma faisait n'était adeline
de fanfan la tulipe esmeralda de notre
dame de paris
la reine de saba pauline borghèse avant
de vous retirer au milieu des années 70
de la vie cinématographique pour vous
lancer dans la photographie et dans la
sculpture un oui c'est à dire que avant
le cinéma
ma vie était la direction d et la
peinture la culture et par hasard le
destin a décidé que je devais aller de
l'autre comptoir le côté du cinéma alors
vous et lancer dans la photographie
ensuite dans la sculpture et vous
exposez aujourd'hui au musée de l'amener
à paris du 10 octobre au 4 janvier
des sculptures que vous avez réalisé on
regarde à quoi ça ressemble marier tôt
[Musique]
c'est bellissima pelo capriccioso karine
ici ma peur aux capitals à mado pas
toutes au mip yatchi négatif à tchô
finis ta vaisselle bolbec ropéro sont
comme benneteau solo gamme d'hôtels et
d'auto débilité madore potocki hamon
tu as
pour ceux qui ont du mal à dire aux
élites shalit est allé
hello
mais basta que tout celui dont pas un
seul but on me parle
cambridge aux hadjis là alors il ya une
monumentale esmeralda de bronze qui fait
5 mètres de haut et 48 15 mètres 50
oh là là oui excusez moi fais attention
à ce qu'on dit 500 bêtes 48,48 quintaux
elle pèse c'était inespéré d'accueil à
votre visage donc chaque fois c'est fait
je n'ai jamais eu qu'une esmeralda ces
risques dans les deux années de travail
ouais pour faire ça c'est sérieux ouais
bien sûr alors immortalisé dans le
bronze et le marbre il ya d'autres
personnages de vos films la reine de
saba il ya pauline borghèse et puis il
ya des femmes que vous admirez comme à
une bonne raison invoquée c'était une
copine que j'ai eue là le plaisir d'être
avec elle je suis bien marrée humaine
d'euros je l'adoré c'était une femme
très sensible très vulnérable et elle a
payé très cher d'être design idole dans
le public je vais très près d'elle elle
a jamais eu de chance avec les hommes un
manoir et oui quand on est belle on est
beaucoup de fois usines - il y avait le
sex appeal des lequel tout le monde
connaît et il y avait cette fragilité
dans son visage et le téléphone près du
lycée rappel de la fin qu'elle a fait
jean arnaud didier vous devriez faire
des réponses plus longue
les gens trouvent ça trop amassés
des toits alors je vois dans le carré
viiip je vois notre ami jack lang pour
lala tout seul comme une puce jack lang
copains bonjour les amis ça va ça va
très bien pu des amis des douceurs jack
vous connaissez la vous connaissez jean
je connais peu il a épinglé il a eu pas
vraiment me faire du mal
est ce que c'est vrai ce que j'ai ouï
première décoration française qui est
deux fois il parle de looter chevalier
des arts et des lettres
je ne l'oublierai jamais parce que je
n'ai jamais vu une fête avec caméra au
glaçage à tout moment mais jade jacques
vous à vous avez peint glé une médaille
et ils vont passer le st voilà c'est ça
non c'est un fou mais là je suis très
maladroit et puis j'étais ému il a pas
l'habitude j'ai aimé oui c'est vrai
j'étais surtout émus par partie de
l'assemblée
jack rassurez-vous baffie arrive alors
pour parachever cette présentation gina
on peut dire aussi vous êtes
ambassadrice de l'unicef
et puis que vous avez mauvais caractère
vous avez un très mauvais caractère non
moi j'aimais défend je suis seul à la
voyez je suis seul mais je vais défendre
et bien parce que j'aime caractère ou
nous a hélas pas mauvais caractère d'un
caractère comme ça votre votre vrai
prénom jean assez luigina louis gars
comme louise et luigi nadjina djin djin
djin alors votre père était assez
et il avait une fabrique de meubles une
entreprise de cordonnerie et des terres
ici un oui il appelle encore du temps
aux giants chacun il est très entouré
c'est un ministre très très connue très
aimé il est là pourtant seul seul comme
un pestiféré et j'espère que quand il
sera président il sera reconnaître les
amis qui l'avaient ceux qui auront
transmis lui notre affection fallu un
gros poutou et j'avais dû transmettre
bien des choses qu'il a fait lui un
bisou laurent tout à l'heure un bisou
laurent on fait d'abord le risoux
laurent depouilly
alors on va y arriver un père très
sévère un jean a pas de cinéma pas de
pantalon pas de garçons 1
sinon c'était le bâton oui ils ont mal
d'amour beaucoup mais beaucoup battu et
oui à bord est vraiment l'éducation
c'était très dur mais je dois dire
franchement je ne le regrette pas 1
je ne regrette pas parce que quand même
une éducation très dur ça donne du
caractère et une éducation trop faible
c'est pas bon à thierry un autre qui
n'est pas bon ici oui c'est le buffet
alors qu'est ce qui se passe lors mon
ici respecte l'abbé pierre mais de là à
le prendre comme traiteur ont dit non
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas là mais pierre laurent c'est
jean jacques le guen bien en 1944 jean à
quand la guerre éclate en italie quand
les alliés remonte l'italie donc votre
maison est détruite par les
bombardements et et à ce moment là votre
famille est obligée de quitter la région
vous habitez pour aller à rome annoncée
la fin de l'opulence là vous vivez à 6
dans une pièce c'est une période très
difficile de votre vie jean à vos soeurs
sont obligés d'être ouvreuse dans des
dans des cinémas et vous vous dessiner
des portraits de gi's dans la rue oui
aussi
oui et 10 ont tous la famille m'a aidé
parce que moi j'étais l'artiste de la
famille et ils se sont sacrifiés et on
m'a aidé pour que je puisse je pouvais
enfin étudié la peinture
alors pour payer justement vos études
artistiques un vos parents acceptent que
vous fassiez de la figuration
que vous preniez des leçons de chant et
là vous vous mettez à faire ce qui est
très à la mode à l'époque en italie des
romans photos et puis ensuite vous
passez du roman photo aris hébreu le
jaune d'or petites touches un ouais
c'est sûr chaque semaine on rajoutera
comment il va jack lang alors ils
s'emmerdent grave il est tout seul ce
type était très entouré encore dans les
années 50 m a pris la somme
fonctionnement qui viennent parce qu'ils
s'ennuient alors ensuite vous passez
gina du roman-photo au cinéma grâce à
silvana mangano la fameuse vedette de
riz amer alors ensuite vous êtes gina
vous êtes miss italie 3 troisième miss
italie troisième derrière l'outil à
bosser et diana maria canale j'avais
comme des super gonzalez à l'époque où
michael dauphine carré quand tu vois les
trois premières la wii et après quelques
films en italie donc vous allez à
hollywood
appelé par le milliardaire howard yupps
alors vos amis qui ne connaissent pas ou
par duke il faut savoir que il était
très intéressé par les formes dire
qu'ils destinaient des avions et des
soutiens gorge
c'est très très incertain a été très
intéressé par les formes aérodynamiques
howard schultz
il vous a fait venir à hollywood awards
yoox et tout
vous avez compris tout de suite qu'il
voulait coucher avec vous on peut le
dire j'étais déjà marie jamais mais
c'est tellement et jenny était un ange
un et vous l'avais pas fait quand même
oui j'ai tu t'aventures echo awards
eugene à la sculpture te dis c'est pas
pour les publics maintenant d'accord
alors donc vous vous résister dit vouer
à ward use et vous repartez en italie et
là effectivement il vous envoie ses
avocats ward youmzain il vous met d
essayer de me faire raisonner avant les
vôtres voilà et vous avez déjà essayé
très années ouais donc voilà donc ça
passe pas bien avec guardiola faut bien
reconnaître en 52 fait fanfan la tulipe
de christian jacq avec gérard philipe
prix de la mise en scène à cannes énorme
6 millions 7,2 télé spectacle de
paiement s était vraiment les débuts
d'ee ma carrière internationale je dois
aller français mon succès ça c'est la
vérité vous pensez quoi du remake de
fanfan la tulipe avec vincent perez et
eneurope et crous et c'est une autre
chose
on ne peut pas toucher des bijoux comme
papa l'atelier point spécialement parce
que il n'ya pas chaque jour et gérard
philipe
non il y a à gérer l'imprévu le film ça
vous a déçu annoncé bosser de harland
l'oreille ça va prendre forme résiste
selon aulas
apple act up un stock de finatis comme
on dit aujourd'hui
ensuite vous jouez avec un très beau
gars pour houston ensuite esmeralda la
reine de saba et là vous êtes une star
mais je crois que les gens se rendent
pas compte que vous étiez à l'époque moi
je m'en souviens vous avez rencontré la
reine elizabeth vous allez rencontrer le
président eisenhower
vous étiez vraiment la reine du monde
quoi ils ont même invité tous les chefs
d'états généraux lecture ouais c'était
quand même intéressant 1 mais j'étais
très très limité par le premier iphone a
brisé nos alors ensuite c'est très
bizarre gina parce que vous faites tout
un tas de films qui n'ajoute rien à
votre filmographie pourquoi vous avez
fait des films moins bien après parce
qu'il n'y avait pas vraiment un choix
étrange et me suis rendu compte qu'il y
avait vraiment ni au mieux de ce que
j'avais fait 1
je me suis dit ah c'est lé moment où un
jeu qui tu es j'ai fait c'est que
vraiment j'ai dans le coeur alors dix
ans j'ai travaillé je ne montrais ni à
la presse ni à personne n'y a rien et
cette année je me sentis je me suis
senti prêt pour le montrer seulement
j'ai exagéré parce que j'ai accepté
trois expositions 1 1 à moscou 1,38
sculpture après belize et paris mon dieu
ne me touche pas
alors bien sûr c'est vrai
le rêve pas personne ne me l'a pas donné
tout ce que j'aimais l'acheter avec mon
travail
voilà alors et laurent vous avez perdu
une boucle d'oreille à l'heure à l'hôtel
à l'hôtel je vais perdre une bourgogne
un gps du budget paix juste non ça c'est
le vrai ça se voit ça s'est déroulé sur
une boucle d'oreille à la salle r - il
est très bon il faut aider les humains
quand même le grès l'euro alors sophie
un coût social
le bémol eux
gina vous n'êtes pas satisfaite de votre
carrière d'actrice nous est pas
satisfaite non plus de votre vie
amoureuse
non non pas du tout pas du tout le bon
dieu m'a donné du talent et il m'a dit
de l'autre côté la vie privée 10h01 j'ai
dit ok 0 serre que vous avez toujours eu
beaucoup d'admirateurs
moi le premier d'ailleurs un amoureux
devant mais jamais le grand amour non
pas une seule fois lorsque et non parce
que les hommes
ils sont très jaloux ouais et quand il
ya une femme belle et populaire
on a peur d'être le parent annonceurs
bah oui c'est sûr bah oui parce que
enfin c'est toujours une femme s'est pas
spécialement nous et européennes on ne
veut pas dominer dominé non non à vous
êtes vous êtes en amour j'ai choisi et
après j'ai fait semblant d'être nominé
c'est ce qui est mieux même que vous
avez été mariée mais bon voilà vous
étiez en 49 avec 1000 cause kotick était
un médecin d'origine yougoslave et
bodmer vous a dit si tu dois te marier
autant que ce soit un médecin ou un
avocat
parce que comme ça au moins tu manquera
jamais de les améliorer en terre gelée
basta ouais maintenant j'ai besoin d'un
avocat gêné et 30000 mais vraiment c'est
pas c'est pas un
c'était une catastrophe non en fait ce
qui est terrible c'est que ce milko qui
était médecin et ce qui est mon ami tu
en as pour l'eau il a quitté il a quitté
la la médecine pour devenir votre
manager non oui après il jouer au tennis
ouais
l'aveuglé et le soir ils étaient
fatigués mais lui vous n'avez jamais
aimé en fait j'ai fait quand même même
fils mans alors rien dire ça ne veut
rien dire
c'est un enfant qui n'a pas bougé elle
en a fait
il est méchant plus ils savaient pas ce
qu'ils vont faire un autre je me
rappelle plus mais au moins 15 années
vingt quinze années avec lui sans
l'aimer c'est bien alors vous êtes
séparés donc en 66 et divorcé en 71
seulement parce que tu sais comme les
premiers à l'époque voulait pas divorcer
et pas elle même d'un film du barça ni
la formidable non non elle est jolie
très jolie elle est là et les élèves
d'avoir un bon mais il est beau il faut
être dur dans la vie pas si la carrière
ou non je suis motard des loups il y à
une telle méchanceté que vous ne pouvez
même pas savoir où ça va nous inquiéter
simplement se détendre respect mais le
cvl vie avec l'homme le plus détesté des
français
il a plus de bijoux que toi
et là des chaînes en or comme qu'on n'a
jamais est ce que vous connaissez joey
starr et ses musiciens mais les
musiciens y aura là c'est le rappeur le
plus il fait ça regardez regardez
sur la corde à linge sale
c'est un artiste formidable il a voulu
me tuer une fois pour vous dire il est
très très méchants dont il voulait jouer
avec mon corps oui bien alors bon on a
vu milko le le médecin qu'est devenu
votre manager mais il ya eu d'autres
liaisons sans gêne à dans votre vie il
ya eu sinatra frank sinatra
j'étais très près dans un des films à
hollywood bowl un sens plus en plus
écoutée
moi tout ce que j'ai voulu dans la vie
jet li yu le yul brynner aller oui et
non avec yul brüderle s'est exclu du
bruit quand je sais curieux parce que
c'est arrivé que on faisait des scènes
d'amour en paix ensemble à c est quand
même il y avait dans le contact il y
avait quelque chose de dd
tu arrives dans les veaux meilleur nom
alors du mien viana yaris et les choses
de la vie
c'était tellement embarrassant parce que
c'était embarrassant parce que quand on
s'embrassait le directeur des stocks
mais moi je n'écoutais pas lui non plus
continuer à vous angoisser on se les
garder non c'était embarrassant et à
lorient n'a alors là vous pourrez pas
dire le contraire parce que l'uimm
il a été assez mal élevé pour le dire
n'ont pas et s'il a publié les lettres
c'est le professeur barnhart alors ça
c'est un sujet qu'il faut tourner la
page tout de suite
écoutez on tourne la page d'après mon
avis est il à briser des coeurs aussi
l'a pas fait que le réparer fidel castro
debout il disait qu'il était amoureuse
de moi et livre la bn admiration pour
moi oui il est pas trop volage fidèles
pas volage est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
jenna pour une interview et en dames
gina quel a été pour vous le plus bel
âge de votre vie maintenant quand on
commence à voir d'isola liberté il
complète de faire vraiment c'est qu'on a
dans le coeur
il n'y a rien d'autre qui s'épuisait
pourtant des ça quel a été pour vous le
pire âge peut-être la guerre mais j'ai
appris beaucoup parce que quand on peut
super et la guerre on est forte
un sas a aidé dans la vie ce que vous
préférez dans le cinéma le cinéma que
j'ai vécu les cinémas où il ya les
sentiments où on peut rêver ce que vous
détestez dans ce cinéma là le 10 heures
la pornographie ah oui vous n'aimez pas
la pornographie au cinéma non mais
qu'est ce que vous n'avez pas dans le
cinéma pornographique trop de gros plans
parties truquées
il faut rêver certains les erreurs et il
ne faut pas aller tellement loin que on
enlève complètement l'imagination et les
plaisirs d'un clic
le film de vous que vous préférez alors
je préfère un film que j'ai fait avec
belmondo ou jetés l'aide est quand même
j'ai réussi à donner et à faire une
belle interprétation la mer à boire j'ai
créé qualité le film de vous que vous
haïssez je ne me rappelle même pas sans
fond la turlutte c'était moyen
votre plus belle histoire d'amour alors
c'est quoi c'est que j'ai maintenant
avec toi mon petit neveu un vote que tu
nourris des huîtres qu'il est toujours
avec moi quand je travaille et fait
semblant enfin c'est le fils de milko
juniors c'est ça voilà quelle est votre
plus minables histoire de moi ça il faut
les oublier pour parler j'ai ma dernière
question ce que vous préférez dans le
sexe quand il ya le sexe et l'amour
parce que le sexe ça peut satisfaire
quand on est jeune mais après on veut
quelqu'un même quelque chose dany des
plus concrets ce qui vous dégoûte le
plus dans le sexe c'est par le biais de
quoi du sexe avec la mousse et c'est ça
tout est facile maintenant
alors jean à vous pensez quoi de la
situation dans l'italie de berlusconi
quand berlusconi dit mussolini n'a tué
personne il envoyait les opposants
politiques en vacances je vais pas
commenter tout ce que c'est disons
politique la seule chose que je peux
dire que pendant la guerre les juifs ont
été tués et tout le monde le sait et
c'était une chose que l'on n'oubliera
jamais spécialement pour les juifs et
berlusconi s'en souvient pas moi hein je
suis très loin de la politique mais vous
savez que c'est pas vrai vous savez
comme ils sont terribles mais berlusconi
lui pendant la guerre il sait bien ce
qui s'est passé avec moi
[Applaudissements]
j'accueille maintenant jack lang
[Musique]
vous êtes vive la peinture lalalalalala
lors on regarde ce qui s'est passé en
italien non enfin dans l'âme et du coeur
parce qu'ils l'ont très très sale jack
lang mesdames messieurs donc très bien
chaque année au laquelle cochon ce type
oui c'est terrible
laurent méfiez vous de ce type diack je
vois que vous êtes habillé en art 10 ans
ce soir pourquoi parce que vous êtes
artichauts un accord très bonnes
réponses première belle réponse de de
jack la zéro mardi sony the way
le jour où je vous rencontre est alors
on vous voit souvent jack à la télé vous
prêtant aux facéties imaginé par les par
les animateurs mais ce soir je voudrais
qu'on change un peu de registre car vous
figurer dans tous les sondages comme un
excellent candidat possible de la gauche
aux prochaines élections présidentielles
en 2007 donc on arrête de rigoler on a
en face de nous mesdames messieurs
peut-être le prochain président de la
république est en sous sol comme une
merde dans le carré vip tous il va
diriger un pays doit diriger le pays en
hauteur on les enfants attention
al'inverse de fabius d'ailleurs qui lui
a la crédibilité mais n'a pas la
popularité voilà et il a par ailleurs
beaucoup de talent ouais c'est vrai
qu'il a toujours été très sympa avec
vous et lui et moi avec lui et vous avec
lui on va voir si ça continue jusqu'en
2007 voilà la recette socialiste jack
lang le plus populaire chez les les
jeunes et les ouvriers et vous dites
quand on vous parle de cette candidature
possible
pourquoi devrais-je les gens qui disent
compter sur moi et donc ya pas de raison
que vous soyez pas sur les rangs en 2007
mais c'est une question qui ne se pose
pas aujourd'hui
un 2007 c'est loin comme un laissez nous
vivre
1 en gros c'est oui quoi nom en grosses
et nous sommes aujourd'hui et j'ai envie
d'agir
ici et maintenant toute une série de
sujets et un ça va être chaud ps à être
un petit peu la guerre des chefs non et
non pour l'heure on joue au jour
collectif off
mais oui on joue collectif ils sont si
l'on veut gagner ce que vous dites là
mais qui est il faut jouer comme excel
et pas perso ouais bien alors vous avez
aujourd'hui jack lang 64 ans vous aurez
67 ans en 2007
c'est votre dernière chance si vous
présentez pas en 2007 façon après ça
sera trop tard
alors avant de passer au crible vos
idées politiques on va dire un petit mot
de l'école d'autant plus que vous publié
chez gallimard folio un livre de 768
parce que j'ai lu je suis sûre laurent
et quelle voix
c'est intéressant ce polluant
oui je suis pas d'accord avec tout mais
ça ya au moins des volontés et puis on
se demande pourquoi tout n'a pas été
fait alors qu'il était ministre et c'est
un point de vue intéressant alors le
titre du livre c'est une école élitaire
pour tous ah c'est pas celui que j'avais
pas vu les trois premiers mois
sérieusement il école une école élitaire
pour tous c'est un oxymoron en quoi
c'est comme la force raf où il comme
vous parlez bien tiré c'est pas possible
ça une école élitaire pour tous
précisément c'est le seul paradoxe de de
ce qu'on doit faire pour un col c'est à
dire un fois une école de l'excellence
mais qui soit en même temps une école
pour chacun on cherche par quelle
méthode vous comptez y arriver et vous
dites si à partir d'un socle de
connaissances solidement acquis par
chacun nous réussissons à libérer et à
reconnaître la diversité des
sensibilités des talents c'est la vérité
je crois c'est la donnée à l'ensemble
des enfants du pays une culture scolaire
de base ray et en même temps et
notamment au collège à leur permettre de
de vérifier ou plutôt de révéler leurs
talents divers à travers des matières
qu'ils choisissent eux mêmes
vous dites on ne peut accomplir un
changement qu en captant les ondes
positives vous rendez bien compte que
c'est très beau enfin je veux dire c'est
pas pratique c'est pas quelque chose de
factuel dans ce domaine de l'école
or les autres on ne change pas en
prenant les gens de frau mais en
essayant d'additionner ce qu'ils ont en
eux de positif
ça me plaît bien oui c'est pas faut
faire accoucher
1 ce qu'ils ont de positif et de
créatifs on ne sait pas plus rapide de
virer les mauvais ah ben voilà c'est
rapide
c'est l'échec absolument immédiat et
quelques-uns de mes collègues l'ont été
prouvée on ne les retrouve aujourd'hui
ne cite aucun nom ne veux citer personne
pense à ferry là à oui sûrement bien
alors là vous risquez pas de vous mettre
mal avec les enseignants parce que y'a
rien de négatif sur sur un vous dit en
parlant des enseignants ce sont les
serviteurs de la pensée dont la noblesse
et des veillées dans les enfants le
petit prince qui sommeille pages à 62
ans non mais vous risquez pas de vous
fâcher avec eux la mais pourquoi me
fâcher avec elle je lis aussi beaucoup
de beaucoup de respect pour eux et je
pense que le que le pays doit d'avoir
beaucoup de respect pour eux parce
qu'ils font un métier à la fois beau
mais très difficile enfin vous avez rien
non plus contre le corporatisme dont les
enseignants font montre certaines fois
vous dites être corporatistes et bien
souvent aimé passionnément son métier
riche et par exemple défendre sa
discipline par le prof de lettres défend
les lettres il aime passionnément son
métier quand le prof de maths défend les
maths 20 il aime passionnément son
métier et j'aime les gens qui aiment
leur métier
faut être un petit peu démago c'est vrai
des fois pour réussir en politique il
faut aussi avoir les idées très claires
alors comme vous parlait très bien pour
éviter que vous embarquer dans des
phrases comme ça on va faire une
interview
oui non
alors c'est que c'est oui non à ça va
être très dur pour vous jack lang très
dur serez vous candidat à la candidature
pour l'élection présidentielle de 2007
oui non joker ça commence à pensez vous
avoir les qualités jack lang pour
diriger un pays comme la france deuxième
choqué non non bâti à la batterie c'est
très grave je ne ris pas tu n'as que
joker 1g pas me porter une appréciation
est ce que vous êtes en train de faire
c'est très grave parce que ça c'est ça
fait penser à d'autres hommes politiques
bien d'accord mais la question ne se
pose qui disent joker à chaque fois
qu'il ya un problème on les canadiens de
la dodge car oui nous sommes en 2003 oui
en 2007 la question se poserait de rabat
pensez-vous jack lang que vous feriez
mieux que les autres
c'est possible donc c'est oui
pensez-vous être crédible au niveau
international un peu qu'ils acceptent sa
toile gerba où ça veut dire oui bah oui
c'est une litote oxymoron l'état
oxymoron l'état social rhétorique ce
soir excellent g mais on n'est pas chez
cauet là c'est sûr alors jack
si vous étiez président est ce que vous
seriez pour l'arrêt augmentation de
l'impôt sur le revenu je serais pour une
égalité fiscale qui passe inévitablement
par l'impôt sur le revenu donc vous
remets trier l'impôt où ils étaient
avant tout pour refaire toute la copie
fabriqués dans des fûts raffarin donc
oui augmentation de la csg pour boucher
le trou de la sécu oui non ce sera fait
avant que l'eau chouaieb les candidats à
la présidence de la république
est-ce que vous baissez le gouvernement
s'y est ce que vous seriez les crédits
pour le ministère de l'intérieur
oui non ce n'est pas une question
essentielle pourquoi baisser les crédits
il s'agit de les mieux répartir donc il
dépassera pas pour la défense baisses
seraient les crédits il faudrait au
chaud dans la défense ne pas s'enfermer
dans le nucléaire et choisir un système
de défense opérationnelle aujourd'hui
qui permettra à la france d'être
présente sur les terrains d'opération
d'accord nucléaire ne sert pas à grand
chose
par contre ne voit pas d'intérêt
non et dont les interventions efficaces
et avait 11 phrase mais on sait pas
c'est que de toute façon pour la défense
des compris que jack ne baissera pas les
crédits mais qui veut mieux répartir
l'argent fallu affecté à autre chose
acheter un truc dépasser acheter des
requêtes par exemple tu serais électeurs
c'est ce sont des pensées de l'argent
qu'on jette à la poubelle
etes-vous pour ou contre la
régularisation des sans papiers
oui oui voilà une bonne réponse à
tapotage tapotage la dépénalisation du
cannabis
oui non je suis pour une loi sur les
drogues pas seulement le cannabis
l'alcool le tranxène livrer le suis pour
que surtout au delà d'une loi 1 que l'on
ait le courage d'organiser une vraie
campagne sur la santé publique trade et
informer les jeunes des dangers qu'ils
courent et pas seulement avec le
cannabis mais avec l'alcool et d'autres
drogues infiniment plus dangereux
la télé réalité tout ce à quoi on peut
en parler est ce que vous êtes pour la
légalisation de l'euthanasie
oui parce que je ne comprend pas que la
france sur ce sujet comme sur beaucoup
d'autres se cachent les choses et et
refuse de de légiférer et d'autres pays
je pense à la hollande imaginer des
systèmes dans lesquels il ya des verrous
des précautions dès des commissions de
médecins qui épaulent la famille et qui
décide
d'accord donc l'euthanasie c'est oui à
l'indépendance de la corse
oui ou non non etes-vous pour ou contre
la dissolution du front national non
l'euthanasie pour le touriste à rendre
le front national victime arrive donc
vous laisser leur iphone battre
autrement par d'autres moyens bien
est-ce que vous êtes favorable à ce que
la gay pride devienne un jour férié
elle est déjà quasiment se détestant la
république jamais plus un enfant
n'aurait
pensée triste c'est merci jack je
rappelle le titre de votre livre une
école militaire pour tous merci job là
république jamais merci jean ah merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous on va
vous laisser aller vous coucher
[Musique]
bien vu jack les tagueurs sens là ça
c'est vraiment un hommage qu'on vous
rend ce soir parce que c'est vous qui
avait fait rentrer le tag au louvre
quand même je crois qu'on peut qu'on
peut le dire donc paulo
elle n'est jamais encouragé
contrairement à ce qu'on a raconté le
quelques-uns il en faut bien pour
écouler je sais que si votre meilleur
ennemi le plus sympa c'est moi même à
bonne réponse merci bravo
j'accueille maintenant h al wafi
[Musique]
et
bonsoir madame un bonsoir bienvenue
parmi nous alors vous êtes la mère de
zacarias moussaoui qui détient aux usa
depuis août 2001 et qui d'après la
justice américaine aurait dû est le 20e
pirate de l'air dans l'attentât du world
trade center
et bonne nouvelle on a reçu cette
semaine on a reçu jeudi une dépêche afp
qui dit l'accusation ne pourra pas
demander la peine de mort je crois que
pour vous c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'exceptionnel j'imagine un juge
américain a interdit jeudi à
l'accusation de demander la peine de
mort contre le français zacarias
moussaoui inculpé par la justice
américaine de complicité dans les
attentats du 11 septembre 2001 voilà on
est au repos
merci beaucoup on va reprendre les
choses 2 0 le 13 septembre 2001 à 7h30
dans votre lit vous êtes réveillé par
votre fille qui vous dit réveille-toi
allume la télé il ya zacharias ils
disent qu'ils l'ont arrêté parce que
c'est un terroriste
pour vous c'est le début du cauchemar je
dis c'est pas vrai question j'allume la
télé
y'a rien et j'attends à 8h30
il y a il ya cette lecture de dépêches
de tous les matins et c'est là où je
vais jacassements là je reconnais pas
mon fils parce que j'ai jamais vu comme
ça et vous voyez la photo qui a c'est
pas possible c'est pas mon fils et
j'attend jusqu'à 9 heures parce que je
sais que la dst il m'a laissé des
coordonnées au cas où vous la détestez
vous avez appelé un petit peu avant déjà
et il avait des doutes un peu sur ce
qu'ils aiment suivre ce qui faisait pas
à quoi
oui la dst l'idée est venue me voir la
première fois c'était un beau début de
2001 me demandant si je connais où il
est mon fils zacharias judy non je lui
expliqué que 90 97 il est venu me voir
en me demandant pardon pour tout qu'est
ce qui s'est passé et on a gardé le
contact à peu près
et je pense six mois il me téléphonait
pratiquement deux fois par semaine et
elle m'a demandé d'aller le voir donc
j'ai pas voulu aller le voir parce qu'il
m'a dit qu'il va réserver une chambre à
l'hôtel jeux ludiques ou tajine rien à
faire si je viens pas si je suis pas
avec ma victoire
toi tu viens il ya la maison est grande
elle m'a dit moi je suis dans un foyer
et que je ne peux pas tu as menée dans
un foyer où il ya que les on est donc je
suis pas allé alors zacharias donc on
vous le dit après présumé être le 20e
pirate dans les attentats du world trade
center
six chefs d'inculpation dont 4 mérite la
peine de mort
et là vous recevez une lettre quelques
jours après de lui qui vous dis maman
j'ai rien fait je suis innocent
effectivement c'est là où le cac est
compliqué zacharias a été arrêté en août
pour un problème de visa expiré et le 11
septembre quand ont lieu les attentats
il est en prison depuis déjà un mois oui
voilà donc ça c'est quelque chose qui le
disculpe ah oui mais en même temps quand
il a été arrêté il s'entraîner au
maniement des boeing et il disait qu'il
était plus intéressé par le dise à son
professeur de de pilotage qui étaient
plus intéressés par les décollages que
par les atterrissages
non ça ça n'existe pas dans ce dossier
monsieur je vous le dis je vous écoute
par les avocats qu'ils ont le dossier en
main ils ont rectifié ça en verlan
les médias américains la seule chose
pourquoi ils l'ont arrêté c'est qu'ils
ont senti que ilité pas à l'aise ayant
il y avait un moment qui est que prendre
des cours de pilotage
la personne qui lui donne des cours il
lui demande qu'est ce que vous faites
pour le ramadan et là mon fils est et
six tickets et il a trouvé ça c'était
bizarre et le monsieur qui lui donne des
cours dudit et il pense pourquoi il
était complètement tout à fait bizarre
et c'est ça qu'il attirait l'attention
de satom pour avertir livia voilà alors
en janvier 2002 vous fait un premier
voyage aux etats-unis vous voyez pas
zacharias car le fbi elle devait
enregistrer la la conversation
les avocats vous dise ne n'y allez pas
parce que c'est un violations donc des
droits de la défense
vous êtes allé aux états unis sans le
rencontrer le 22 avril donc 2002
zacharias comparaît devant une cour en
virginie alors là c'est terrible parce
qu'il nie sa participation effectivement
vous avez aux attentats du 11 septembre
puisqu'il était en prison mais reconnaît
être un guerrier de l'islam il appelle à
la destruction du peuple juif et des usa
et remet sa vie entre les mains dallas
il dit je suis un esclave dallas enfin
bon ils se présentent comme l'archétype
du terroriste admirateur de ben laden
est il dit si un jour je suis remis en
liberté je passerai ma vie à tuer des
américains
donc là même s'il n'avait pas été mêlé
aux attentats du 11 septembre pour les
gens devant lesquels il comparaît il est
coupable d'une certaine façon oui
je comprends que c'est des mots très
très grave mais il faut avoir les
conditions pendant que quand même 11
mois où il était donc moi je pense et
j'ai vu c'est un homme qu'il était
blessé et milliers pour moi comme je
connais zachary fier comme il est touché
dans son honneur dans son que c'est une
forme qu'il va le fouiller qui dit il a
eu l'occasion de parler
il a dit que le pire des choses qu'il
peut dire qu'il verrait d'un bon oeil à
10h par énervement par énervement parra
vengeance par des repères du mal de
l'autre côté par un ils l'ont fait du
mal si tu n'est guère cas même si chez
qui lui en a mené les amériques
alors là il récuse ces avocats et il
annonce vouloir se défendre tout seul
alors vous y allez et le 12 juillet 0,2
donc il plaide coupable sans doute il a
trouvé un accord avec l'accusation pour
échapper à la mort vous pensez qu'il a
été manipulé au moment où il a plaidé
coupable
c'est à dire que john walker était dans
l'un d'eux mêmes
à côté de lui lorsqu'il faut dire voilà
excusez moi madame je vais expliquer nos
amis téléspectateurs johnnie walker
c'est le taliban américains les les
services fédéraux l'ont mis à côté de de
zacharias est donc à ce moment là et lui
d'ailleurs ce john walker a obtenu une
remise de peine en plaidant coupable et
ont pensé qu'ils l'ont mis là pour
convaincre
zacharias de plaider coupable
donc mon fils est là qu plaidé coupable
juste le moment que diana car il a
plaidé coupable et a pris il s'est
rétracté d'ailleurs une semaine plus
tard oui il ya il a arrêté de plaider
coupable alors ensuite il a entrepris de
prouver son innocence en demandant
l'audition de responsables d'al-qaïda
détenus par l'armée américaine en disant
écoutez convoqué les ils vous diront que
je suis pas mêlé à tout ça alors le juge
était ok mais le gouvernement américain
a dit non on se retrouvait dans un ce
qu'on appelle un trou noir juridique
avec pete solution on a parlé de
tribunal militaire est là s'ils passent
devant un tribunal militaire
et bien sûr que le condamné est celle à
qui est arrivé cette dépêche donc
l'accusation ne pourra pas demander la
peine de mort contre acariès moussaoui
pour vous il est innocent pour moi il ne
te sens bien sûr pour la pente aïe ça
c'est sûr et comme c'est lui même qui
l'a connaît qui lui permet le qaïda et
par les sages c'est lui qui le sait
mieux que moi un mois je peux vous dire
que pour l'attentât du 11 septembre ça
y'a pas de doute il n'a rien à voir
ouais alors est-ce que vous pensez que
cette décision de la justice américaine
est dû à une intervention du
gouvernement français pas dit ou non
ouais je pense que la france est là
devoir envers mon fils mon fils il est
né en france citoyens français oui et
donc il faut qu'il réagit la france
comme comment citoyen français pour
monfils simon fils et il est abandonné
bord de parole le gouvernement français
les américains ils sont capables de
faire n'importe quoi avec mon fils jack
vous pensez quoi de cette affaire
d'abord je veux dire que je pense que
c'est ce sentiment aussi de madame avec
le terrorisme
nous devons avoir aucune aucune
complaisance et donc que nous avons tous
été
révulsée révolté par le 11 septembre et
par d'autres actes terroristes
c'est une chose est sûre laquelle il
faut être créée elle énerve
deuxièmement le terrorisme la lutte
contre le terrorisme ne peut pas
justifier les atteintes aux droits de
l'homme qui sont habituellement commises
par le gouvernement américain sans doute
à l'égard de votre fils mais aussi à
l'égard de toute une série de personnes
aujourd'hui je pense notamment à ceux
qui sont aujourd'hui à guantanamo qui
ont été capturés en afghanistan
voici deux ans sans aucune protection
sans aucune transparence sur leur
situation et donc il ya là manifestement
une atteinte aux droits de l'homme et la
procédure de jugement équitable et les
etats unis aujourd'hui se rendre
coupable d'acte contraire disons au
droit international ajoutons à cela que
dans l'intervalle il ya eu
l'intervention en irak était une
intervention elle même illégale
illégitime mais ça c'est un problème
plus général
aujourd'hui le la mairie se trouve dans
un véritable fiasco en irak mais pour
revenir à votre fils je crois que le le
devoir du gouvernement français qu'il
doit accomplir est un devoir de
protection diplomatique et j'imagine que
le consul à washington lui a rendu
visite
parce que je suis allé le voir le du
mandant comme mon fils quand il est
ils l'ont arrêtée il y avait personne de
gouvernement français qu'il est parti
voir mon fils de quel état ou de quelles
conditions il était mon fils si
vous-même duquel certaines autorités
pensent que j'ai demandé à la dst et au
quai d'orsay pour mon fils alors
zacharias est en prison sous un régime
très particulier qui s'appelle le régime
supermax c'est le plus sévère dans les
prisons américaines il a une cellule qui
fait 6 mètres carrés la lumière était
allumée jour et nuit
il est réveillé toutes les demi-heures
n'y a pas de fenêtre il a droit à rien
ouais je peux vous dire même si plus que
supermax subir mac saison certains
droits lui il a droit à rien mais si
votre fils est imaginé gotti soit
coupable
imaginez c'est un instant le fait qu'ils
se soient fait arrêter quelque part ça
lui a sauvé la vie parce que s'il avait
été dans l'avion je serais plus là
aujourd'hui
donc en tant que maire se séparent si
mon fils y avait des preuves conquois
unités
ni de cet attentat grand moi que je
n'aurai pas de la force devrait remet de
dire un mot
parce que d'avoir tant de morts 3000
morts je ne peux pas parler ce n'est pas
possible c'est incroyable mais je peux
pas j'ai je veux me mettre dans un coin
à pleurer pour mon fils mais je peux pas
le défendre comme je fais maintenant
mais à partir du moment que mon fils
n'est pas 1000 et de sa justice mme
qu'il a droit d'avoir un procès
équitable mais une raison de plus que ce
qu'il m'a fait peur avec les américains
quand j'ai vu qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
en irak
ils ont respecté aucun droit de
personnes aucune loi entre nationaux et
je pense est là mon fils il est en
danger mon fils est une goutte d'eau
dans le sillon si l'on parie ce petit
tout un peuple
comment respecter mon fils et toutes les
bombes qui sont tombées à nérac
je me sentais est tombé sur moi et vous
pouvez demander mon docteur g prétendent
de médicaments j'ai arrêté de regarder
la télé je me sentais humiliée aussi
parce que c'est pas possible un peu plus
fort le plus grand géant de du monde
entier tapie sera un peuple comme ça moi
j'ai dit mais mon fils il est foutu
et je pense quand même qu'il les
français ils vont pas laisser monfils
tombé sur tout le gouvernement
j'étais très fier d'être avoir
nationalité française qu'un que le
gouvernement français la tenait tête
pour ça que cette guerre mais les choses
ont changé et il ya beaucoup des choses
en jeu je le comprends mais c'est pas
une raison d'un de laisser mon fils est
un sacrifice pour les américains
c'est bien
[Applaudissements]
alicia
les chirac s'est opposé à la guerre
d'irak
il peut obtenir des américains que votre
fils ait un procès équitable
si vous l'aviez en face de vous jacques
chirac vous ne diriez quoi je veux lui
dire monsieur le président la vie de mon
fils il est entre vos mains et deux mois
le sauver s'ils méritent une
condamnation parce que hélas
emile et avec ce mouvement qui les
malfaiteurs s'ils méritent une
condamnation faut le faire mais pas une
condamnation à mort ni une condamnation
à vie parce que pour une mercedez sûrs
s'il arrive ça mon fils aujourd'hui et
peut arriver à quelqu'un d'autre alors
c'est pas possible de laisser les
américains faire qu'est ce qu'ils
veulent avec les enfants des autres
merci aux humains
ecoutez-le chat ça va déjà mieux qu'il
ya une semaine
oui beaucoup mieux merci j'ai bien oui
oui petit à petit petit à petit oui je
sais que si tu courageuse mais à notre
combat parce qu'il faut il faut y aller
les empêcher de condamnés à vie parce
que je vous dis pas qu'un joli devant et
en face de moi avec qui ne m'a en chine
y est que j'embrasse la vitre pour
embrasser à un enfant que j'ai fait au
monde et que je n'ai plus le droit de le
voir ni le torchis je le souhaite à
personne c'est tout qu'est ce que je
peux vous dire c'est très dur mais j'ai
fait devant lui je fais la forte parce
que je sais qu'il dit maman je veux que
tu sois forte je suis là je viendrai
j'ai rien fait confiance je lui dis oui
mais quand je sors de là crois moi que
je ne vois rien tu vois rien je sans
rien vous êtes courageuse merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant bien sûr je vous emmerde
j'temmerde j'temmerde et je t'emmerde
joue les quêtes ou les monnaies guen
tous les fronts je reste concret
tirer c'est la guerre des matches où
celui qui c'est un mec tôt mais la
mairie ouais si m6 jean gabin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
calais
[Musique]
m6 jean gabin bonsoir bonsoir
alors quand on vous demande pourquoi m6
jean gabin parce que c'est vrai que vous
dites je pouvais pas prendre alain delon
parce que c'est un facho un trou de
balle exact hu est exact que prend
maintenant que j'en garde un pendage
avec jean gabin puisque dans les acteurs
que j'aimais bien quand j'étais plus
jeune il y avait jean vient pas le
maurice principal meurice et habib sy
courbine alors vous êtes un fan faut
dire aussi des tentes en plein coeur de
touche pas au grisbi de mélodie en
sous-sol aux 4 paul dike ont été
retrouvés c'est bizarre mais bon enfin
c'est pas la wii vous êtes un fan des
tontons flingueurs de touche pas au
grisbi
mais l'audience sous sol cc ou qui à
charles qui est un ancien braqueur sait
dans quel film
c'est dans un mail audience où le sort
et la vie en sous sol
ça tombait bien en fait parce que vous
vous êtes un ancien braqueur et puis
votre vrai prénom ses chars ses chars
ouais c'est peut-être pour ça que vous
avez pris m6 en faisant couler de source
ça coulait de source vous connaissez
jack lang
oui j'ai vu là juste à l'heure 1-1 et je
connaissais en tant que ex ministre
fils de fritz lang vous le connaissez
vous béatrice même si jean gabin
connaître tous les rappeurs vous l'aimez
bien oui à paris un trip dans sa chanson
qui vénèrent 28 de ses vrais amis dans
sa chanson l'aï dit du mal de bruit on
voulait ben j en veux il sait pas qu il
explique ses raisons de toutes vérités
ne sont pas bonnes à dire entendent donc
à partir du moment après c'est les sa
divergent
il ya des pour y aller contre et vu que
tu es proche
excuse moi de te tutoyer twente donc
voila quoi parce que bon ça réduit
vachement excuse-moi défendre parce que
je connais qu'évidemment c'est des gens
que j'aime
ouais mais maintenant biwetz france à
pagis à moi je trouve ça juste dans dans
la mesure où je me dis que c'est une
génération
c'est la première génération de rappeurs
qui a eu c'est à dire à ntm pas biais de
formats people et de bio ss ce sont
ceux-là qu'ils ont prôné on était contre
tours excusez moi ni tuer le système ils
sont rentrés les deux pieds dedans
le moulin intérieur clapet ils font
exactement la même chose que les gus
qu'ils ont critiqué avant que tu
m'excuseras tu peux pas critiquer sur la
rai me balancer la gazelle derrière il
ya un truc je te regarde et je t'ai dit
ça va ma gueule terrible chouette ouah
c'est quoi ça c'est c'est facile de
prendre un fanion
voilà aujourd'hui c'est la misère ou
comme donc en politique c'est la
sécurité jean verdon morceau i feel
thiva supermarché tu vas gagner
vachement d'oseille tu vas pas peut-être
en profiter aussi ce que je trouve ça
pas normal quoi tu vois je serai prêt à
ce que je fais avec mon l'oseille pour
l'instant j'ai pas de fachos pour aller
toucher non mais après quand les mecs
ont dû fixer en leur dis ouais les mecs
vous rentrer dans le moule
maintenant on sent qu'il est où il ya un
bal en place nous donne a changé ils ont
dénoncé des choses qu'ils ont vécu
qu'ils ont fait à un moment
énoncé la sauce guèye a pas de problème
il ya un moment quand tu critiques jean
et court 10 ans qui fait de la soupe et
tu fais exactement la même chose que
gynéco tu m'excuses à l oral c'est une
musique comme une autre et à de l'avarié
dans la rue des muguets vous ne faisait
pas de variation pour moi ce n'est pas
le vieux cesseront de la barrière c'est
tout temps coûtant quand les rentrants
olé olé c'est vrai je t'emmène je suis
les cours resteront
c'est la guerre les braves tous les
lycéens alors votre vrai nom c'est donc
charles ambush d'origine camerounaise
née en 67 père comptable mère dactylo et
vous êtes 5e qui sur une famille de 12
voilà alors quand vous avez neuf ans vos
parents divorcent et votre père supporte
pas et vous dites il repasse il repasse
votre mère et son nouveau mec dans un
parking voilà 37 rue saint forgeot en 77
moins doués un repas c'est ça veut dire
assassiné quand à signer les est
assassiné comment c'est d'abord il a
touché mon pays la touche et le conjoint
au mur ouais et après il s'est occupé de
ma mère ouais moi j'appelle ça c'est
celle ash ouais c'est sita début on ne
tend pas besoin de faire tout ça en plus
si la personne veut plutôt à ça lui dire
au revoir et bon voilà salut à part
amener votre mère en tous les cas ça va
pas me ramener non plus mais voilà voilà
ensuite vous dites il part en calèche
c'est à dire en prison il ya il a pris
combien de paires bon à mon père il a
fait en tous sens et qui gênent oui
c'est à dire tous les jeux c'est pas
beaucoup
bah ouais cinq mois après il a fait
autant que moi pour braquo ouais voilà
pourquoi bon on y mentionnait le crime
passionnel et en plus cela il a eu du
bol plus yeux il a échoué il a échappé
au couperet
ouais ya 81 81 2 c'est la peine de mort
est témoin aurait vu ses 170 ans donc
j'ai pas capté on voit là et soit après
cinq années pour braconnage web
braconnage
j'ai fait cela pendant mon sens
il est où votre père mon père il doit
être duplex là quelque part par là moi
ça va c'est son problème mais vous ne
voyez plus gras cherche moi ouais voilà
donc vous à l'époque vous partez à la
dass vous parlez de la dass en
expliquant que finalement les abus
sexuels sont très fréquents c'est
fréquent est beaucoup plus fréquent que
les gens croient ve et le bizutage
le bizutage est fréquent mais le
problème c'est pour en revenir
maintenant avec les ctf qu'ils essayent
de faire je sors des centres techniques
éducatif est dans un centre technique
éducative tu apprends qu à une chose
savoir que ceux qui ont ce qu'on te
promets n'existe pas moi je veux un coup
un numéro donc tu doit rapporter tu es
déjà adultes avant l'âge donc la société
avant tu sais que c'est une variante va
rien amené c'est que du pipeau ouais et
le problème dans ces trucs là c'est
quand vous êtes enfermé pour ce qu'ils
ont la famille c'est bien pour ceux qui
n'ont pas faut se démerder donc abus
sexuels de toutes sortes et quand vous
avez une petite greluche qui passe ça y
va aussi vous dites temps meilleurs amis
c'est à force ça tu as ton meilleur ami
7,1 fourchette parce que quand tu rends
à 13 ans quand tu aurais tu as quand tu
rentres à 13 ans en maison de correction
puisque c'est comme ça c'était fou sans
technique éducatif vaut mieux avoir deux
trois poteaux quant à 13 ans car on aura
moins de problèmes avec ce 17 mai
raconte quand vous rentrez vous en avais
12 10 il ya peut-être d'autres problèmes
avec ce 17 mai qui justement n'ont pas
de bons rapports sexuels avec la gente
féminine s'occuperont des plus petits
voilà alors à 17 ans vous vous retrouvez
à paris et là vous découvrez le hip hop
mais la branche dure du hip hop à la
dépouille
1 la dépouille était un moyen de
détecter survivre un braqueur quoi ouais
ces braqueurs de petite envergure les
petits faubourg way rapide une paire de
chaussures et la rapine son blaze et
rapide tout doucement
c'était pas des banques qua non les
banques c'est venu plus tard et a failli
à l'enfer 2 basé e l'acheminement social
justement vous faites les petites
institutions jusqu'à aller jusqu en
calèche en calèche vous apprenez l'école
du vice et
dehors ben c'est soirée ratée puis
junior ou un casse dalle mais
franchement préféré l'autre ouais vous
êtes dans le gangsta rap à ce moment là
non non j'ai j'écoutais du games europe
mais avouez vous circulez avec les
requins vicieux quand même c'est pas des
mecs très à elle retient vicieux sont
mes amis dont les cousins mais les
requins vision avant tout c'est une
famille on était justement ce qu'on
s'est servi de substitut parce qu'on
avait pas chez nous zoua aperçoit une
mère est forcément les plus faibles à ce
fonds occuper les plus gros seins et
dedans il faut manger donc chacun son
activité de 3 et mérite salaire
et voilà voit alors un moment ça
commence à sentir le roussi pour vous un
charme et vous partez en allemagne et là
vous tombez pour braquage j'ai fait cinq
ans que thomas ben moi beat now mobile
tegel 1
c'était une bonne expérience car dans
les mauvaises il faut apprendre et dans
les bonnes il faut apprendre aussi là
j'étais dans une mauvaise mais elle m'a
servi de beaucoup servie chaude et b
limite je maintenant je commence à
jacter de troie qui l'engagent en plus
ouais on va réellement bien quand même
un problème qu'est ce que ça vous a
appris à part à part l'allemand à part
l'allemand que
quand vous arrivez par exemple dans un
beau pays comme la france où
théoriquement c'est l'eldorado et on
voit où on vous accueille avec un grand
sourire
1 alors que de l'autre côté est
théoriquement c'est des fois chaud des
néonazis alors que vous pouvez trouver
un travail en ayant quatre épingles sur
le sur le terrain on vous vend rien
tandis qu'en france fait la même chose
en bo3 alors parce que l'habit fait le
moine à vous ressortez de cette tôle à
berlin à 27 ans au total vous savez
comme été enfermé 17 ans ainsi on fait
le convoi s'est dit plus la lâcher cette
pige avec la calèche ne faisait pas
attendu le rap pur est révolté vous en
tous les cas non pas du tout
alors vous disiez tout à l'heure que
joey starr faisait du doc gynéco ce
qu'un peu exagéré mais non vous c'est
gynéco qui vous a demandé de devenir rap
est alors au début je n'avais rien à
[ __ ] vouliez faire un bouquin au
départ ouais au départ je voulais faire
un bouquin ouais puisque je voulais
toucher une autre partie de la populace
est bon gyneco il m'a appelé et je me
suis pris au jeu
voilà mais ça vous plaît ouais c'est ses
marges
alors vous en êtes vous avec la justice
maintenant avec la justice bas ça va
j'ai juste cinq ans de mise à l'épreuve
et pour cocaïne
ouais pour cocaïne pourra vous dire et
de la cocaïne ah ouais je survis
1 je survis il faut il faut le savoir
moi quand on me dit l'argent sale c'est
vrai l'argent sale mais l'argent sale à
la rive sur quelle table 1 vous regardez
ce qu'ils font leurs trucs là avec leur
pétrole et leur baratin à gauche à
droite en 10 sec de l'argent propre
mais c'est là qu'arrive à hank haney
s'ils vont jamais un mois j'ai besoin de
manger je suis dans un bled où je suis
né où j'ai fais pipi de la nation ça
fait 8 qui gémit j'ai pas mes faf on
peut le dire j'ai pas mes fers faisait
pas de papiers pas de papiers je suis d
ici j'ai fait l'armée j'ai été exemptés
à chaque fois que j'ai quelques mois
comme ça un baratin de france 5 en un
donc un moment je me dis hé les gars
voulaient pas que baic
je vais becqueter même si je dois aller
à la rate energy a raté hier mais j'irai
manger parce que la vie c'est pas tant
de la part c'est quoi la ratez rien
c'est la prison c'est pas la calèche
assez la même qu'à tel qui allège donjon
raté hier avaient pris place ont alors
attaqué vous avez peur de retourner en
prison
c'est pas que j'ai peur de retourner en
prison mais je voudrais pas y aller
ouais vous dites c'est la haine pe du
vice c'est là une paye du fils ya aucune
réinsertion tu n'auras jamais ton
prochain larcins c'est clair je suis
resté douze mois avec un gus s'appelait
josée-anne entier qu'ils aient les bras
qu à l'ancienne les postes etc
et moi je suis rentré dedans mais en
n'ayant rien fait ou même en ayant
offert un petit fils pendant 12 mois
j'ai appris en théorie comment braquet
ouais c'est tout ouais les mecs qui vous
adhérez dénommé course était mon prof
mais c'est pas très bon profil mais
qu'elle est derrière les barreaux sa
valve ne s'est pas grave tu apprends des
erreurs des autres diack c'est quelque
chose à dire non parce que c'est le
président est exempt n'aurait des mecs
comme lui mais j'écoute avec avec
attention je redis la manière de
raconter sa vie qui est qui qui touche
qui est très proche d'audiard ses vrais
rivaux pas seulement écrire des du rap
est vrai qu'il ya des films maintenant
un bain
sarkozy les lois sarkozy vous en pensez
quoi réchauffer c'est du réchauffé
c'est du réchauffé du réchauffé qu'est
ce qui va changer
ils parlent les tapant à longueur de
journée tu vas sur le périph qui
pourfend otites fait sucer une trique
ses films ok sarkozy attend parce que ça
ça m'a fait rigoler c'est une carte de
mon client tu peux revenir quand tu me
charles vous croyez en quoi je crois en
moi ouais l'amour oui mais c'est
malheureux de croire en l'amour et c'est
malheureux d'état moore et pouvais pas
croire en l'amour
ouais voilà votre mère elle vous aime je
pense que ouais ouais
votre grand mère aussi ouais votre fille
est aussi ma fille aussi
donc vous croyez au moins à l'amour de
ces trois femmes ouais ça c'est clair ça
s'arrête là ouais vous prions dieu
pas du tout pourquoi parce qu'il ya wen
est jamais venu au parloir
j'avais vu et jamais vu au parloir et je
pense que quel est le père qui
laisserait crevé ses gosses sans jamais
bougé le petit doigt
mais leur servent quand même c'est la
faute des z'arts well medef aussi c'est
pas la peine
aussi alors donc voilà donc dont je
t'emmerde on l'a dit tout à l'heure et
béatrice dalle vous tapez sur
l'intégralité du rap français même joey
starr qui pourtant me semblait à l'abri
quand même de ce jardin d'attac
alors on va me faire une interview si on
disait du bien
[Musique]
alors chat quand même si jean gabin si
on disait du bien de joey starr vous
diriez quoi ça a été un précurseur à moi
tu vois si on disait du bien de kery
james vous diriez quoi bon rappeur de
kool shen récurent sur de lord kossity
grande saucisse à vous arrivez pas vous
arrivez pas à dire du bien de l'ordre
que c'est justement un ss et pit
baccardi pit baccardi bon pique assiette
aie pitié vous avez vous aller taguer où
les enfants sont prises sont formidables
ce que le décor ils leur font mais j'ai
l'impression
excuse moi quand il leur faut en verre
je ne vois pas beaucoup changé ces
propos de choses à lady laistee où vous
oui la jolie petite arrière train de
nouveaux seins tout neuf à
m6 ceux là bas je lui tire mon chapeau
c'est l'un des rares qui est toujours là
ouais ouais voilà qu'adamo comme un ipad
il a pas tourné savez s'il arrivait un
peu le même jeu là même j'avance du
début jusqu'à la fin que la cena dans la
variante salut je suis là la rumeur
j'écoute pas trop où tous y est
politique car c'est pas mal à la rumeur
laisse à chacun sa soupe
doc gynéco ouais merci mon pote voilà
mais ce qui fait comme musée ce qu'il
fait comme musique-là var est il le dire
ma island où il est vraiment un l et
2000 à moins de succès qu'avant à la
roue tourne ouais mais bon je pense
qu'il a il a fait son job
voilà et puis si maintenant il veut
tirer sa révérence qu'il attire ce que
beaucoup devraient faire d'ailleurs un
effet avoir les moyens de tirer sa
révérence arriola ça fait déjà 10 piges
qui sont là je pense qu'ils ont pris ça
y est ils ont rêvé dentier maintenant
donc je suis va falloir commencer
on
précédés
el mami
[Musique]
j'accueille maintenant nicolas baverez
nicolas baverez ce bonsoir vous
connaissez jack lang
oui oui oui bien vous connaissez m6 jean
gabin c'est la première fois que je le
vois vous allez vous en faire un jeu
lent et que je l'entends mais ce n'était
pas fini de le voir béatrice dalle vous
connaissez oui laurent baffie voilà
alors nicolas baverez et historien
économiste éditorialiste au point et au
monde et est pourquoi sur la quatrième
de couverture de votre livre vous dites
pas que vous êtes avocat chez bradford a
parce que j'ai d'un côté un métier
indépendant qui me permet de gagner ma
vie puis de l'autre avec cette
indépendance j'essaye de contribuer au
débat public mais je ne mélange pas les
deux alors ça fait plus de dix ans que
vous intéresser au déclin national
nicolas faisait déjà publié les trente
piteuses et vous allez publier un livre
qui s'appelle le 21e est mal parti voilà
ça c'est l'esprit d' havraise 1
alors aujourd'hui vous publié chez
perrin la france qui tombe gros succès
de librairie un énorme
et puis tout le monde en parle c'est à
dire que vraiment vous avez des tas
d'articles dans les dîners on parle de
vous le présenter république est très
énervé après vous pas vraiment vous avez
su créer l'événement alors pour vous la
france est en plein déclin ne s'est pas
l'exception française c'est le déclin
français alors les symptômes de ce
déclin
la croissance est en chute un chat même
pas la peine d'épiloguer tout le monde
le sait il ya le chômage 20% des actifs
en âge de travailler en france sont au
chômage
oui et surtout 25 ans de chômage de
masse avec des effets donc terrible sur
certains pans du territoire
et puis des populations entières où on
se retrouve avec trois générations de
chômeurs la dette nationale qui est de
1000 milliards d'euros c'est-à-dire 62 %
du pib contre 23% en 1981 vous pouvez
rajouter 2 100 milliards sur les
entreprises publiques 30 milliards de
sur la sécurité sociale donc en fait on
a au total une dette publique qui
approche les 100% du pipe si vous
intégrez tout ce qui a été tout ce qui
gravite autour et qui en fait devra être
remboursés par le contribuable
les entreprises sont dans la dérive dit
ou alstom après vivendi et france
télécom dans des grands fleurons de
l'industrie nationale française sont en
perdition fuite des compétences c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'exil des des cerveaux
qui vont à l'étranger non respect des
accords européens la france est au
dessus des seuils autorisés par
bruxelles et l'armée pour conclure
l'armée est incapable d'être
opérationnels tout simplement même pas
comme l'armée britannique en irak
très clairement les britanniques ont
pris le leadership stratégique de
l'europe et par ailleurs notre armée
reste organisé pensé autour de la
dissuasion nucléaire
alors qu' il y a des nouveaux risques
notamment les risques de terrorisme qui
ne sont pas ou très mal prise en compte
toute cette crise ce double dites-vous
nicolas baverez s d'une crise morale et
intellectuelle et même spirituelles et
vous dit en conclusion une phrase de
frédéric bastiat la france est une
fiction à travers laquelle tout le monde
s'efforce de vivre aux dépens de tout le
monde voilà alors poème c'est que bastia
il écrivait ça en 1848 et il ya toujours
eu des gens de droite finalement pour
dire que tout allait mal que c'était
fini il ya eu la gueuse au début du 20e
siècle la gueuse la république a pris au
moment du front populaire on disait
qu'on avait remplacé l'esprit de travail
et de sacrifices par l'esprit de
jouissance donc finalement même si votre
analyse est juste
en tous les cas n'est pas nouvelle
toujours des gens pour dire ça il ya
deux éléments dans ce type d' analyse il
ya effectivement un côté idéologique qui
correspond à un aspect rhétorique de la
tradition de droite dans ce pays
et puis il ya un autre élément qui est
la réalité historique il est un pays qui
a des hauts et qu'il ya débat dans cette
histoire dans les années 30 par exemple
on ne peut pas nier qui est que cet été
une décennie de décrochage sur le plan
économique sur le plan militaire et que
ça s'est très très mal fini
donc aujourd'hui je pense c'est sans
doute pour ça que se livrent à du succès
que ça n'est pas un livre idéologique
c'est un livre qui part d'une analyse
des faits ensuite on peut discuter des
solutions
alors pour vous finalement le slogan qui
résume un peu la situation de la france
aujourd'hui c'est le slogan du punk
c'est no future oui c'est à dire qu'on a
deux côtés cette situation de décrochage
de l'autre une absence de projet
politique
de la droite et de la gauche donc au
gouvernement est pour l'instant dans
l'opposition un est donc derrière la
montée de l'extrémisme et notamment de
l'extrémisme de droite parce que depuis
la fin de l'union soviétique
la révolution est repassé à droite et
puis la montée de la violence sociale et
la violence sociale
on la voit poindre on l'a vu avec des
conflits comme les intermittents on l'a
vu avec des comportements ni liste on
l'a vu par exemple avec un certain
nombre de gens qui comme ils savent
qu'ils vont être au chômage avis
menacent de faire sauter leur usine ou
d'envoyer des éléments le dos au mur des
produits polluants mais c'est parce que
c'est pas admissible d'avoir ce type de
comportement d'un côté mais de l'autre
ce sont des gens qui sont désespérés ils
sont désespérés parce qu'on est dans un
système qui est bloqué a les poils de
son bouquin qui est très important et
que vivent douloureusement des tas de
gens aujourd'hui c'est la
désindustrialisation
je vois dans l'endroit où je suis moi
même dès aujourd'hui à boulogne sur mer
dans le pas de calais en général
quasiment chaque mois des charrettes de
licenciements en ce moment c'est une
entreprise métallurgique de comilog 350
personnes qui est fermée tandis que aux
etats-unis pour dés avec une politique
peut être discutable on s'est bagarré
pour préserver l'industrie de l'acier
avec des moyens éventuellement
discutable ils portent concurrence aux
pays du tiers-monde mais enfin en
attendant les américains ont su pour la
recherche scientifique pour la
préservation leur agriculture pour la
défense de leur aciérie et laure
d'industrie prendre des mesures je
dirais efficace pendant l'environnement
comme un sûrement à volants rayonnement
et spécialement pas au texas
nicolas dit tout le monde n'en fait qu'à
sa tête selon sa fantaisie re fins et
dostoïevski l'a dit avant vous
d'ailleurs alors qu'il faudrait
respecter quelqu'un ait quelque chose à
ça c'est très droite ça c'était cette
idée que finalement c'est parce qu'on
respecte rien que ça va mal non c'est
pas une histoire de respect c'est un
problème de projets politiques regarder
partout autour de nous on a parlé des
états unis on peut discuter lusage qui
font leur puissance mais ils ont un
projet qui est de garder leur leadership
mondial après l'avoir reconstruit
l'allemagne son projet politique c'est
l'art et unis
le royaume uni c'est d'être l'allié
privilégié des etats-unis en europe et
d'avoir la maîtrise stratégique et
diplomatique de l'europe l'espagne c'est
de rejoindre le peloton de tête des
européens
quel est le projet aujourd'hui politique
que la france eh bien je pense qu'il n'y
en a pas et que c'est ce qui explique ce
désarroi
c'est vrai moi je veux pas désespérer de
l'iran nous écoutent oui enfin bon je
crois un futur naturellement mais il
faut être honnête sur ce plan et nicolas
babel a raison aujourd'hui on est sur le
plan dit long de la réflexion sur le
futur dans une sorte d'impasse le
gouvernement nous conduit droit dans le
mur et je dois dire honnêtement que le
parti socialiste qu'elle a pris plein
les gencives il ya un an 1
j'en ai pas encore remis et nous avons
besoin d'eux il n'y a pas nécessité
d'agir dans la minute n'ont besoin de
réfléchir de prendre conscience aussi
que le monde a changé à la révolution
génétique
la révolution numérique la révolution
économique tant de choses ont changé
qu'on doit absolument prendre en
considération si on veut être honnête
vis-à-vis de ce don demain nous
demanderons les suffrages pour le moment
nous ne sommes pas prêts alors justement
vos critiques les plus acerbes bon
gouvernement raffarin visite qui a
dilapidé le 21 avril comme jospin avait
dilapidé les années de croissance
mais si vous reprenez les choses dans la
durée d'abord les responsabilités de la
situation actuelle sont mélangés
notamment par la cohabitation
on a eu deux périodes de croissance
forte à la fin des années 80 à la fin
des années 90 1
la plupart des autres pays ont rétabli
le plein-emploi pas nous le deuxième
élément c'est qu'en 2002 comme on l'a
dit il ya eu ce cri de désespoir des
français il ya eu derrière tous les
moyens d'agir que les données 82% des
voix au président de la république une
majorité de 400 députés sur 577 à
l'assemblée le sénat toutes les
institutions de la république
voilà trois cinquièmes des collectivités
territoriales il derrière 15 août et 10
ans sont pas services ont fait le
minimum de réforme ils n'ont pas de
projet et ils ont finalement réduit la
politique du gouvernement à sa
communication
c'est ce que vous reprochez à la fin
alors je crois que la politique c'est
l'action est qu'aujourd'hui à la place
on a la compassion oui alors moi je lis
vos éditos dans le point ils sont
excellents
effectivement il y en a un qui
s'appelait rafa rien et ça c'était
c'était assez serré derrière il y en a
beaucoup voulu pour ça et c'est pour ça
que chirac vous en veux beaucoup
il ya un autre qui était extraordinaire
en tous les cas le titre était très
accrocheur c'était deux bouts devant
busch coucher devant blondel et ça
résume malheureusement assez bien la
position de la france aujourd'hui
alors pour vous et là on en arrive
peut-être à un sujet qui peut vous
opposez tous les deux pour vous
l'attitude de chirac disons face à la
guerre d'irak face aux américains vous
dites c'est munich enfin les accords de
munich
c'est daladier et chamberlain quand on
dit la guerre est toujours la pire des
solutions
finalement chirac remet ses pas dans les
pattes daladier quoi je crois qu'il ya
quand on veut avoir une rhétorique de
grandes puissances il faut avoir les
moyens de cette puissance est
aujourd'hui comme on l'a vu nous ne les
avons pas la france a dit un certain
nombre de choses justes elle a alerté
notamment sur les problèmes politiques
qui pouvaient suivre une victoire
militaire en irak
évidemment c'était vrai mais elle a
commis trois fautes comme vous l'avez
dit une faute de quitter le terrain de
la politique pour la morale avec ce
pacifisme radical c'est pas vrai que la
guerre est toujours la pire des
solutions
d'autres milieux et vic plein il faut
pouvoir utiliser l'entrée de la russie
dans les talibans si vous arrivez avec
l'étendard du droit vous n'aurez
strictement rien la deuxième faute c'est
une faute de style il fallait opposer la
raison à la passion américaine avec
cette espèce d'emportement nationaliste
et nous nous avons opposé à la pression
l'exaltation l'exaltation une autre et
puis le troisième élément c'est que nous
nous avons fait une énorme faute en
utilisant donc mois menaçant d'utiliser
le véto parce que là nous sommes en
guerre non seulement avec
l'administration américaine mais qui
sommes durablement brouillé avec le
peuple américain
et ça c'est une toutes les plus graves
parce que le gouvernement américain peut
changer le peuple il changera pas pardon
excusez moi nicolas jack lang c'est
cette idée ce qu'il appelle le pacifisme
radical qui est finalement là c'est un
point sur lequel je ne suis pas d'accord
avec nicolas mas vreizh je trouve très
franchement
que le latitude de chirac élu président
la république wright a été une attitude
conforme au droit
le droit c'est le socialiste qui donne
raison à sira quel mec de droite oui
mais ça m'est arrivé plusieurs fois
depuis depuis j'ai parfois se trouvait
seul à défendre le président la
république sur ce type de sujet la
position française
à mon avis c'est quand même sur le plan
du droit international salue d'ailleurs
des médias qu'à pâti dans le monde
entier ce que dit nicolas baverez c'est
que la france c'est bien beau tout ça
mais on n'a pas les moyens
ça c'est une autre question encore on
n'a pas les moyens notre position si on
fait les marioles en fait tout ça
puisqu'il dit en gros il dit tout ça
c'est du cinéma
en fait pour masquer les réalités
intérieur c'est ça que je n'ai pas du
cinéma parce que en réalité de faire des
discours devant l'assemblée générale de
l'onu que de réformer les structures et
comme bien souvent bouger toucher devant
blondel ne mélangeons pas tout parce que
disons que malheureusement
malheureusement les faits donnent raison
à la position française c'est ce que je
vous assure le factuellement
actuellement des américains sans lui en
irak que celui dont tous les jours des
gens sont assassinés des américains d
irak ya des gens de l'onu et par
conséquent la position française qui
consiste à dire rendons l'irak aux
irakiens et la bonne position
alors votre solution parce que quand des
solutions dans votre bouquin mais
entendu vous avez expliqué ce que c'est
c'est la thérapie de choc alors c'est
quoi la thérapie de choc
l'exemple de 58 est intéressant à cause
de ça parce qu'on avait d'abord pris les
problèmes dans l'ordre on avait remis de
l'ordre chez nous dans les institutions
dans l'économie dans la société
ensuite on avait donné des idées à
l'europe voire au monde avec la
diplomatie entre l'est et l'ouest le
nord et le sud rhin aujourd'hui donc
c'est cette démarche qui me semblent
intéressantes et également l'idée
d'inscrire tout ça dans un projet
politique qui permette de transcender
les corporatismes les intérêts des uns
et des autres nicolas parce que quand on
veut réformer sans dire pourquoi et son
ire vers quoi on va forcément chacun se
replie sur ses avantages en gratuite y
avait de gaulle
oui en 58 il y avait de gaulle et
aujourd'hui il y avait autre chose il y
avait la guerre d'algérie la gare de
djalma aujourd'hui aujourd'hui vous
dites 58 58 c'est d'abord de gaulle
aujourd'hui à quel est l'homme politique
aujourd'hui qu'est la stature et le
passé du général de gaulle voulait me
faire dire que chirac n'est pas de
gauche je crois que jack lang sera
d'accord avec cette affirmation
c'est quoi un réponse est ce que la
solution alors il ya peut-être vous pas
vous parler vous parlez de 58 vers une
autre solution peut-être la solution c
47 après la guerre quand la france était
détruite et que thorez a dit il faut te
reste leader communiste maurice thorez a
dit il faut retrousser nos manches
c'est vrai que pendant quasiment deux
décennies alors que la loi des 40 heures
théoriquement était toujours en travail
et 52 heures à l'époque oui les français
ont travaillé entre phases suivant les
époques entre eux qu au départ même 58
eur et je me sers venu ensuite
et puis quand la croissance est revenue
quand le pays s'est mis à remarcher
bien sûr on a on est revenu à des
horaires de travail plus d'hormones et
on a augmenté les on a donné tout une
série d' avantages sociaux imaginons
bouzid nos futurs imaginons qu'ils aient
aucune solution qui soit trouvée dans
les années qui viennent
pour vous c'est le pen qui va tirer les
marrons du feu
le choix c'est le vieux choix de
l'histoire dans notre pays c'est le
choix entre eux la réforme et la
révolution des révolutions c'est
toujours le fruit on en a fait beaucoup
dans ce cas dire c'est les réformes
qu'on n'a pas fait donc aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que c'est ce même choix qui
est devant nous et donc soit nous
modernisons notre pays et ça n'est pas
l'europe où la croissance américaine qui
va moderniser ce pays et à notre place
soit nous allons devant des situations
de crise alors est-ce que ça viendra
d'un mouvement politique est-ce que ça
viendra d'un mouvement social qui
dérapera je ne sais pas mais nous allons
devant des difficultés très grave il
n'est pas douteux que et personnellement
je m'en réjouis pas que cette rentrée
apparemment calme mais ce sont les eaux
dormantes et chacun sent bien
confusément que nous sommes sur un sur
un volcan
et je pense que dans les prochains mois
il va bien falloir prendre des décisions
courageuses qui ne peuvent être fondées
selon
dans un esprit que sur un esprit
d'équité et de justice
il s'agit pas de moderniser en écrasant
une fois de plus les plus pauvres les
plus démunis les plus abandonnés qui
payeront une fois de plus le prix de
changements mais je crois que l'heure de
vérité approche
merci nicolas baverez la france
messieurs maire c'est de tendre un
soutien il ya un truc là-bas vrai ce
dont vous parlez pas dans votre bouquin
c'est que les français ne sont plus non
plus numéro un dans le domaine du sexe
vous savez ça ça c'est la confirmation
que le moral est gravement atteint voilà
et c'est très triste moi je trouve en
tous les cas vous savez qu'on ait
dépassé par les russes les hongrois et
les bulgares
c'est quoi les critères les critères
sais combien de fois vous baisez par
semaine c'est le nombre de fois et
encaissé ça compte pas ah non et oui et
en france ces intrus les premiers je ne
savais sasha
[Musique]
j'accueille maintenant sophie coignard
mesdames messieurs
[Musique]
un diacre hester si vous partez on va
croire quelle heure alors ça c'est que
si vous partez en barillet on va croire
que vous n'êtes pas courageux et c'est
parce qu'elle parle de vous dans son
livre et je pense qu'il est ce qu elle
vivre le livre de sophie coignard
c'est une fête une succès vous qui avez
qui se livre que j'ai fait condamner
c'est un peu plus compliqué que ça mais
ça se savait coignard oui oui c'est moi
alors sophie coignard
c'est pas de votre faute si on nous
cache tout on nous dit rien parce que
vous êtes auteur de plusieurs best
sellers dont la nomenclature à française
l'omerta française et vous publié le 9
octobre chez albin michel
la vendetta française alors l'omerta la
vendetta pour vous c'est pas le déclin
dont parle nicolas baverez 16 mai pour
vous c'est la mafia la france mais enfin
encore que c'est un petit peu à voir
parce qu'effectivement pendant que le
les élites passent leur temps à essayer
de se combattre de se punir etc
ça laisse assez peu de temps la réforme
c'est un petit peu le lien qui a entre
les deux effectivement le lien entre
l'omerta et la vendetta c'est que
l'omerta ça a raconté un petit peu
comment il y à une loi du silence en
france et la vendetta raconte comment en
gros on punit on dise vadon menacent les
gens qui veulent éventuellement raconté
une autre version des choses
jack lang quand il vous a attaqué sur le
bouquin précédent vous aviez dit quoi je
ne sais pas si je peux en parler parce
que monsieur lang saisie assez
facilement les tribunaux il m'a
effectivement fait condamner donc je
voudrais pas que vous soyez aussi
embarquer dans une galère je voudrais
savoir jusqu'où il va évidemment parler
taper comme un héros un bon partage
allez messieurs vincent 1000 euros il en
a eu un pis-aller
elle a gagné beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
en ramassant dans les poubelles
ici ou là les qu'en dira t'on elle a mis
en cause
moi je ne suis qu'un parmi dorin
l'ensemble des journalistes français
l'ensemble de la classe politique
française
eux n'ont pas osé 1 n'ont pas osé
engager une action en justice
moi personnellement j'ai adopté comme
principe depuis que j'ai été calomnié
d'attaqué en effet en justice les
personnes qui vous calomnie qui ne dit
mot consorts bien sûr en gros c'est vrai
que je racontais des choses donc qui
sont pas possible d'être dit sur
monsieur lang que j'ai été effectivement
relaxer
en première instance car le tribunal
considère que je parlais de choses qui
étaient légitimement des sujet de
questionnement
ouais donc voilà et on appelle
effectivement et bien le tribunal a
considéré que je n'apportais pas les
preuves suffisantes juste impossible
d'apporter les preuves suffisantes ce
système est important c'est exactement
voilà sophie coignard ce que je vais
vous le dire mais il veut en venir mais
oui mais c'est devant un jury est-ce que
vous avez des preuves de ce que vous
avancez dans celui là la neige devient
de plus en plus prudents parce que je
viens de dire il ya quand même en ce
moment en france il faut dire les choses
il ya des gens qui font des boucs à spa
pour donner raison à jack lang mais
birenbaum par exemple ou alors il fait
un livre la vie ce bouquin non il paraît
que chirac a un enfant au japon j'ai
écrit à l'elysée pour savoir si c'était
vrai et l'elysée m'a pas répondu
évidemment il s'en est donc l approche
que c'est vrai donc c'est la preuve que
c'est vrai ça laisse rêveur non mais
sérieusement je fais écouter excusez moi
je mets birenbaum c'est lui
et moi c'est moi birenbaum explique au
début que effectivement il est au café
de flore il entend plein de choses
donc c'est une manière d'écrire un livre
fusé dans cette entreprise littéraire
moi je crois cette maudite des allemands
ne travaille pas moi je travaille j'ai
dis pas qu'il travaille pas j'ai dit que
des proches de comptoir je vais dire que
depuis le départ il le dit il assume
il raconte que voilà il entend des
choses qui que quoi donc moi je pense
que je fais un autre travail et si je ne
faisais pas un travail d' enquête
vu que monsieur lang dit que je calomnie
l'ensemble des élites je pense que
j'aurai beaucoup de procès car
finalement les lois les lois sont
extrêmement dire la plupart des gens
n'osent pas je vois bien passé ça séjour
ne réagissent pas au brésil en auge pas
faire de procès parce qu'ils se disent
que finalement ils vont être calomnié je
n'ai vécu moi-même non pas une fois mais
deux fois trois fois à l'occasion de
chaque instance juridique et moi j'avais
parfaitement que vous pouvez calomnie en
quasi impunité
non mais c'est comme la ferme de 10
comme je veux dire que ça qu'on dit des
trucs qu'on dit détruit puis après tout
le monde aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui se
passe sur la sphère mode l'hypocrisie
généralisée personnes étaient vêtues
carreau minier par la plupart des jours
de france et de navarre
aujourd'hui sainte nitouche ah le pauvre
monsieur baudis n'est même pas d'
excuses de la part de ceux qui l'ont
dénoncé calomnie et ridiculisé barillet
affaire baudis est en soi un un vrai
scandale c'est pour ça que je dis ça que
les gens soient dégoûtés de la politique
des hommes publics mais baudis a été
terriblement attendra et la calomnie
donc ce que vous dites dans ce bouquin
c'est pas juste des trucs que vous avez
entendu au café du commerce
bon café de flore comme notre ami
bientôt je veux pas me poser à bien
nommé en l'espèce voilà j'ai figé
enfin voila j'ai fait trois ans bancaire
et j'en ai fait un bien alors vous êtes
chez bic et on va dire ce cas dans ce
bouquin quand même expliquer tous les
modes de vendetta là il ya la
psychiatrisation saluant dit le mec est
fou alors vous parlez du substitut lévis
la guérilla fiscale parler des derniers
à l'époque où il voulait sortir son son
pamphlet jeunes à être vous parler d'
arnaud hamelin qu'est le producteur de
la cassette méry donc voilà alors arnaud
hamelin effectivement il avait la
cassette méry en main parce qu'il avait
tourné les confessions de jean claude
méry donc un faux facturier qui avait
arrangé beaucoup d'affaires de marchés
publics avec la ville de paris
et quand il a eu cette cassette en main
qu'il a commencé à les voir les
télévisions pour leur dire voilà j'ai
quelque chose d'intéressant
jean claude méry était mort il avait dit
que la cassette ne pouvait être divulgué
qu'après sa mort eh bien il a commencé à
avoir des soucis des petits coups de fil
lui disant c'est dangereux de se
promener avec une bombe dans sa pole je
préférais et puis il a eu un contrôle
fiscal
voilà alors c'est toujours difficile
parce que le contrôle fiscal est magique
le contrôle fiscal vous avez beaucoup de
mal à dire j'ai eu un contrôle fiscal à
face à mais jamais arrivé mais ça
pourrait venir
je pense que ça va venir et donc j'ai eu
un contrôle fiscal parce qu'on en veut
parce que je suis persécuté
c'est évidemment là vous passez tendance
psychiatrisation allait être
complètement parano sa table etc
mais en vérité ce qui se passe c'est que
le l'histoire d'hamelin et est assez
clair il a une société de production 1
il se faire redresser ce fiscalement
pour des choses qui n'ont provoqué aucun
redressement fiscal pour toutes les
autres entreprises du secteur donc il ya
une énorme disons coïncidence 1 voilà
oui alors vous parlez de vendée temps
entre patrons alors vous raconter
l'histoire qui a opposé matra
c'est-à-dire lagardère à thomson
c'est-à-dire gomez alors là c'est
extraordinaire c'est d'une violence
totale tchèque les mecs vraiment c c'est
grave quand ils vont chercher des des
officines on peut dire clymène demeure
sur les gens et en fait
le patron de l'époque
de thomson alain gomez par le biais d'un
avocat va réussir à déclencher une
campagne pour essayer de démontrer que
matra a lésé des petits actionnaires est
assez fictif mais ça va faire énormément
de papiers dans la presse pour
discréditer matin alors après vous
parlez de la course à l'elysée ça
intéressera l'un d'entre nous ici bien
qu'ils ne soient pas déclarées un tu vas
te présenter charles à la présidence
oui tu as raison voilà un bon second
déjà
alors donc la course à l'elysée vous
dites que chaque écurie présidentielle
dispose d'un cabinet noir par exemple au
moment des élections
chirac contre jose par les rg rouler
dites vous pour chirac il essayait de
sortir l'histoire de la maison de l'île
de ré pour juste pas et puis son passé
trotskiste
enfin en fait oui c'est ça c'est dire
que la wii les l'énergie rouler
chirac y avait un certain nombre
d'affaires qui était monté vendu clés en
main aux journalistes et puis alors je
n'ose pas à soupçonner la dgs c'est dans
les services secrets d'enquêter sur sa
vie privée
ouais donc et villers j'ai dit vous qui
roulait pour chirac 1 et la dgse qui
voulait pour jose pas alors là c'est
l'histoire de faire les histoires de
l'enfant caché au japon dont on nous
rabat les oreilles sans en savoir rien
voilà nicolas ça c'est bien aussi une
une gangrène de l'état je veux dire
c'est le temps qui passe à s'occuper de
ces vendetta c'est bien du temps qui
passe pas à s'occuper des affaires des
français un facteur d'optimisme c'est
que je pense quand même que la tolérance
de la société française diminue
on a parlé de la justice pendant très
longtemps il était impensable d'aller
demander des comptes à des magistrats y
compris on avait certains qui étaient
des fous pour de bon pas à cause de
psychiatrisation on en avait d'autres
qui étaient malhonnêtes
on a vu récemment plusieurs magistrats
malhonnête dont certains sont
aujourd'hui comme vous diriez en calèche
à la télé
c'est la preuve de talent c'est un truc
donc c'est la preuve que quand même il
se passe je croyais encore une prise de
conscience qui chemine et qu' il ya un
certain nombre de comportements qui
maintenant ne sont plus tolérées alors
vous aborder aussi ce fils la
colonisation de l'état qui est colonisé
dites-vous par exemple par les syndicats
d'enseignants et alors là vous parlez de
jack lang le dire vous avez poum poum
tiens ça va recommencer vous dit jack
lang quand il est arrivé à l'éducation
il a mis le drapeau blanc sur le toit et
sur le toit du ministère
et avant même le premier cocktail un
tout de suite vous avez pactiser vous
comme pour être sûr de pas avoir de
batiscan vient pour ne pas avoir de
problème n'est pas cotisé avec les
syndicats oui je ne sais même pas ce que
ça veut dire en réalité quand vous êtes
ministre de l'éducation nationale 1 qui
en effet des organisations syndicales
est-ce que l'une des premières démarches
normale n'est pas de les rencontrer de
connaître leur sentiment de dialoguer
avec l un et je vois pas en quoi ça veut
dire aller saisir en brûlant le drapeau
blanc sur le toit du ministère
simplement il ya eu j'ai voulu restaurer
un jeu aussi un dialogue
1 d'accord j'ai rien à ajouter bien là
comme ça au moins vous êtes accra pas au
tribunal va se parle d'elle-même
alors non il est ric pas bien dans votre
bouquin aller sinon je vais vous dire
c'est moi ce n'est que mon avis mais
quand vous ressortez la sphère copé bon
vous savez l'histoire vous le savez que
je l'avais écrite on a accusé monsieur
copé d'avoir payé des jeunes pour
allumer le feu à des voitures leur donne
en mille balles ou qu'un s'emballe par
voiture l'afer a été jugé il a été
blanchi copé dans cette affaire elle n'a
pas été jugée elle n'est jamais arrivée
jusqu'au tribunal ne risquait pas d'être
jugés s'avancer quoique ça le
journalisme d'investigation oui
d'ailleurs il a rendu beaucoup de
services pour révéler des des mensonges
des concussion mais il faut que les
journalistes d'investigation soient eux
mêmes d'une rigueur intellectuelle
parfaite et je ne suis pas sûr que
madame o cognard je pars pas le sol et
je n'ai pas lu poignard coignard est
toujours manifesté une très grande
exigence dans le domaine de la rigueur
et de l'audience est la dernière chose
sophie coignard moi je suis comme jack
lang je pense que j'en ai de
l'investigation c'est bien il ya des
moments je me demande si vous étiez une
mouche si vous étiez présente quand vous
parlez moment le livre de péan est sorti
le livre contre le monde a écrit par
péan
à ce moment là vous dites qu à une
réunion à la direction du monde avec
sollers avinio les patrons du monde
colombani plenel etc et ils ont décidé
lors de cette réunion de contre-attaquer
en disant que péan était antisémite
est-ce que vous avez la preuve de cette
réunion est ce que vous avez des
informations qui vous permettent de dire
que ça a été décidée là ce jour là
plusieurs personnes vont parler de cette
réunion j'ai interrogé
les gens qui étaient censés participer à
cette réunion et comme je le dis dans le
livre il ya un certain nombre de gens
dans ta le ment bernard henri lévy qui
m'ont dit mais cette réunion n'a pas eu
lieu
en fait ce qui se passe c'est qu'ensuite
effectivement la campagne sur p
antisémites se produit il ya une
campagne de discrédit qu'est lancée sur
péan qui n'est pas du tout sur le fond
de la sphère le monde et sur les
accusations graves qui lance contre le
monde sur lequel personne n'a jamais
répondu
mais qui est sur le fait que p o et
antisémite on lance une rumeur est alors
cette rumeur est bien commence à vivre
sur le fait dans différents milieux il
sauf que daniel schneidermann qui sauve
un livre là raconte une conversation où
il veut inviter donc sur son plateau à
la fois péan et cohen et edwy plenel et
jean marie colombani les dirigeants du
monde et edwy plenel lui dit tu ne peux
pas invité pierre péan cet antisémite
j'ai d'autres témoignages qui montrent
la réunion qui a lu au journal le monde
animal j'en ai la preuve d'un livre tiré
à dix ans entre été détruite jeudi qu'
effectivement au monde 1
un certain nombre de gens au ont cru
voir qu'avec cette réunion que cela
étant les fraudes certains protagonistes
disent que cette réunion n'a pas eu lieu
toujours est il que le résultat c'est
qu'effectivement la campagne conquis qui
visait à faire passer monsieur péan pour
un antisémite ce qui à mon avis est est
une pure hallucinations de l'esprit a
été menée et que c'est ce genre de
campagne de discrédit qui à mon avis
font partie de la vendetta bien quelque
chose ajouté non non j'ai dit et redit
ce que je pense encore une fois quand on
exerce le métier de journaliste
le métier de professeur les métiers
d'hommes politiques on doit absolument
s'imposer une obligation de rigueur
intellectuelle et j'estime que l'auteur
de ce livre que je n'ai pas lu mais qui
a pondu d'autres ouvrages n'est pas
conforme à l'idée que je me fais de
l'honnêteté intellectuelle mais les
choses à répondre s'était cogné à
écouter non je voudrais pas être
désagréables à mon tour vis-à-vis jack
lang
donc je répondrai que pour ma part
je m'estime être parfaitement en règle
avec la rigueur journalistique qui est
de bon aloi
merci beaucoup sophie coignard
boilard la vendetta française
c'est publié chez albin michel
[Musique]
et
et oui jack au lit d'eau de jack pot
mais oui mais oui mais en même temps
président de même on attend on m'attend
à charge à lui qui va pêcher c'est autre
chose en commun
comment tu crois qu'ils les mines comme
ça vous avez vous une formidable c'est
une magnifique
oui on a dit votre âge tout à l'heure
c'est un coin ces couches dans le
congélateur s'est passé merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
difficile en fait un concert
et maintenant
la parade
[Musique]
merci fifty santa
non
[Musique]
bonsoir et de message pour dire pour
éteindre c'est la lumière qui attire les
rappeurs alors fetison vous arrivez du
zénith le concert s'est bien passé super
c'était génial
est-ce que tu as croisé lollobrigida
dans les connais tu as croisé une dame
âgée avec des bijoux se servir
comment comment trouvez-vous le public
français rif thyssen il était super il y
avait un grand une vraie présence est
bien tout le monde était là pour écouter
c'était génial
elle vous aime les gens ici
alors
béatrice dalle vino béatrice dalle non
non je suis désolé lui notifie coignard
et lui c'est mc jean gab 1 mc jean gab'1
kaki et 1,3 à dire voilà et m6 baverel
m6 bat breizh izel à y arriver
même si la vraie ce que ce qui peut vous
mon cher petit cerf cocaïne bien alors
vous savez quand même que fifty sonne
c'est le premier rappeur qui a été signé
sur le label de eminem et dr dre qui
s'appelle choisi louis cordes et quand
vous avez signé le contrat de dr dre
vous a dit es-tu prêt à rentrer dans
l'histoire
quand même c'est vrai que c'est un
événement puisque ils ont choisi ils
m'ont choisi c'était c'était un
événement ils m'ont dit que l'avenir
d'être nouveau oui ça s'est passé
d'ailleurs alors ils ont offert un
million de dollars pour le contrat
vous aviez des offres à un million bulle
6 vous avez quand même choisi eminem et
dr dre 1 parce que sur le plan créatif
je pouvais pas obtenir la même chose pas
qu'une question d'argent
ouais alors vous avez raison de signer
avec eux parce que ça a boosté votre
votre cd et vous en avez vendu six
millions aux usa voilà on va écouter un
petit peu ce qu'il fait parce que tout
le monde ne connaît pas à filtisac à
part mes enfants 10e
dubaï
[Musique]
le gall
à
[Musique]
sur le post la personne c'est ma seule
folie voire un très joli
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les textes à la fois une grave menace
qui a un prix agathe aux magics t
[Musique]
ouais
ça s'appelle pimpé s'est extrait de get
rich or die tryin voilà ça vous plaît
nicolas le hip hop le v6 budget total
est là je vais tuer non mais avec
parking et jeter fabuleux c'est qu'il ya
une limite au dic extraordinaire oui
l'assemblee avec lui donc c'est
vachement bien
bravo ça vous plaise ou non ah si aulas
vous êtes très chanceux parce qu'il est
une personne jean gabin vous êtes le
premier qu'il aime ce soir on a eu du
pot
coup de bol alors on vous appelle
filtisac mais votre vrai nom c'est
qu'artiste jackson vous avez une enfance
difficile dans le queens et dans
l'endroit le plus violent du queens à
new york qui s'appelle saf jamaïca vous
avez élevé là votre mère sabrina est
décédé à l'âge de 23 ans à l'époque vous
aviez huit ans elle vous avez eu à l'âge
de 15 ans votre mère vendait du crack
est ce que vous mettez à faire
d'ailleurs vous aussi dès l'âge de 12
ans et c'est vrai vous dites en restant
huit ans de plus au bahut j'allais tout
juste pour voir décrocher un job qui me
permettent d'acheter une caisse
d'occasion vous dit le deal n'était pas
une solution c'était la seule solution
c'est grave ça grands maintenant ce qui
se passe dans certains cas quand on
grandit dans un quartier comme ça quand
on n'a pas d'argent
l'argent semble à peu près impossible
c'est la solution à tous les problèmes
si on trouve un moyen de trouver où sa
maman elle a fait ce qu'il fallait pour
se nourrir alors après la prison quand
vous devenez papa d'un petit garçon
vous prenez un peu vos distances avec le
deal
milieux du crime et vous rentrez dans le
rap et vous rencontrez vous avez
beaucoup de chance vous rencontrez jam
master jay de renggli m6 ce qu'on fait
la chanson avec aerosmith et vous faites
un premier album qui s'appelle power of
dollars
mais à ce moment là je comprends pas
pourquoi vous commencez vous toucher 250
mille dollars pour faire cet album
et pourtant vous continuez à dix les du
crack comment alors que dire que j'avais
effectivement 250 mille dollars sur le
contrat ouais mais l'avant ce n'était
que de 65 mille dollars et encore 5000
dollars 506 police à la sortie il ya des
limites de la ensuite une certaine somme
pour l'avocat pour les juristes du
compte c'est 5000 $ en poche
j'avais deux pas vivre pendant un an et
demi à dire ça c'était pas bougé et donc
c'est pour ça qu'il a fallu solution
d'accord alors on mai 2000 le 24 mai
exactement vous promener dans le
quartier du queen's en jeep
quand un inconnu vous tire dessus avec
un 9 mm et vous prenez 9 balles dans le
corps
vous arrivez malgré tout à conduire
jusqu'à l'hôpital jamaïca
vous savez qui vous attire et ses neuf
balles dans le corps je n'ai pas
personnellement
cela étant ça vient de ma vie avant la
musique quoi
ouais vous avez peur aujourd'hui encore
nous faire tirer dessus
non non non tu prend 9 balles et
quittant sorte on a rien à jeter
alors voilà donc à ce moment là la
maison de disques columbia refuse de
vous gardez vous retournez dans
landowners vos racines et vous
rencontrer à ce moment là voilà le
manager de eminem est là tout va bien
c'est un conte de fées qui commence
puisque comme je l ai dit tout à l'heure
vous en vendez 6 millions 4 mois mais
vous avez toujours quand même un petit
peu d
et il est toujours un peu des
embrouilles avec la police n'ont quand
même malgré tout nord malgré tout pas de
grosses embrouilles disent oh oui
dernièrement vous avez eu un problème de
port d'armes
vous avez un petit problème de port
d'armes vous a été pris dans une autre
en fusillade
et vous savez quand même que quand vous
allez revenir aux états unis vous devez
allez vous présenter à la police quand
même fifty san vous savez ça la police
est toujours entraînements d'été avec
des trucs qui sont morts pour un flag
alors aujourd'hui tout va bien vous
acheter un château il achète un château
pour mettre le crack il achète un
château à deux heures de new york qui
est un très beau château qui était la
demeure de mike tyson s'est est en train
de racheter pour quand même quatre
millions d'euros c'est pas mal 4
millions d'euros ça fait combien toi qui
sais compter 26 millions oui c'est bien
dit dont elle est belle la maison à ce
prix là non comment attend elle est
comment la maison sérieux et soixantaine
de choses à vous pourrez accueillir des
amis l'instant bien dire à maubeuge déjà
construit un tiers nouvelles idées alors
on écrit un film sur vous aussi le
scénariste des soprano est en train
d'écrire un film sur vous absolument oui
c'est vrai star travaille sur un signe
il sera bientôt tourné
c'est la réussite avec un guide et le
succès des mines m
avec le film de est mal ça m'a beaucoup
aidé et puis c'est quand même un
lancement est bon maintenant il m'aime
bien aussi ouais vous connaissez le rap
français
mais quand une fille française ne parle
jamais
béatrice est ce que ça veut dire ça lui
a traduit nous aussi d'ailleurs du
baston là au [ __ ] c'est joey starr
le mari de béatrice est très très
méchant il a il a failli me tuer une
fois qu'elle me high stakes comme mike
tyson a conduit tombe bien aussi
oui j'ai envie de dire que je mettais
balcon mais c'est vrai oui de pions se
réconcilier ça va très bien merci
[Musique]
merci thank you tube et matches tout
baigne
vous avez pas vous promener dans la
ville et tout ça on va rentrer sagement
la maison merci d'avoir égalé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant
si matthieu ricard
[Musique]
bonsoir donc après que cette violence
après tout ces rappeurs après ses 9
balles dans la peau la calèche lara
teulière un peu de paix vous étiez
chercheur en génétique cellulaire donc
disciples de françois jacob et vous avez
décidé un jour d'embrasser le bouddhisme
voilà donc après le moine et le
philosophe vous publiez chenil plaidoyer
pour le bonheur c'est un livre
passionnant qui m'a beaucoup fait
réfléchir parce que je me rends compte
que j'ai tout faux mais tout faux tout
ce que vous dites dans votre book âge
fait l' inverse
c'est un bon point de départ à c'est un
bon point de départ oui alors des genres
a commencé le bonheur c'est quoi des
sages le coma ce coup de fil on peut le
dire déjà c'est quoi le bonheur
je crois que c'est un état un peu de
paix intérieure de liberté intérieure
notamment de liberté vis-à-vis de la
haine de l'avidité l'arrogance de la
jalousie
c'est un peu comme la profondeur de
l'océan par rapport aux vagues sous les
joies et les peines de l'existence c'est
un peu comme la tempête où le calme plat
la surface mais s'il n'y a pas quelque
chose un peu plus profond 1
et bien c'est difficile on reste
vulnérable
on dépend entièrement des circonstances
extérieures donc bien sûr c'est
difficile de peu à peu cultivé une
certaine joie de vivre et de la
maintenir
alors la recherche du bonheur vous dit
c'est pas voir la vie en rose s'est pas
non plus ne pas voir les souffrances du
monde ça c'est clair mais vous dites si
l'élimination des toxines mental comme
la haine et l'obsession c'est certain si
vous voulez quand quelqu'un a été très
en colère ou a fait du tort à quelqu'un
d'autre
souvent il dira j'étais hors de moi même
je n'étais plus moi-même
on peut pas dire qu'on sent en paix avec
soi mais nain si par contre vous même à
distance vous faites un acte de
générosité pour quelqu'un si cette
personne ne le sait même pas
mais une certaine joie intérieure qui
fait qu' on se sent un peu plus proche
de ce qu'on pense être notre vaudrait
comme ça plus souvent voilà fleury
justement mathieu vous dit le bonheur
est en nous c'est à dire il faut le
réveiller
il faut le révéler parce que le bonheur
on va souvent de chercher à l'extérieur
de nous est en fait il est à l'intérieur
de nous c'est à dire que si on dépend
entièrement de l'extérieur notre
contrôle sur le monde il est limité il
est éphémère il est illusoire passe
quand même la façon dont on vit les
choses dont on traduit les circonstances
extérieures en mal être ou un bien-être
c'est la façon dont fonctionne notre
esprit on pense souvent que le bonheur
viendra à la longue et ça dépend que ce
qu'on fait
la façon dont on cherche pas ce qu'on
peut très bien courir vers le bonheur
justement en le confondant avec
l'euphorie le plaisir l'intensité est en
fait lui tourner le dos justement on
confond le bonheur et le plaisir on
cherche l'euphorie dans les drogues le
cannabis l'alcool etc
mais en fait la joie durable n'a pas
besoin d'être juive en extérieur si vous
voulez sa mort il faut pas confondre les
deux choses le plaisir en soi dans un
mauvais mais si on pense que c'est à
travers de ça qu'on va vraiment acquérir
une satisfaction profonde
le problème c'est que le plaisir est
éphémère il dépend des circonstances du
moment des personnes il se transforme
d'abord on est à neutre et maintes fois
on a des goûts si vous mangez une bonne
glace à la framboise au bout de 3 ou
z'avez bref aller au bout de sa queue
vous avez mal au coeur tandis que si
vous voulez et c'est un peu comme une
chandelle qui se consume au fur et à
mesure qu'on le faisait s'évanouit
tandis que le bonheur intérieur c'est
quelque chose au contraire le plus
approfondi et le mur on le connaît le
plus épanoui le pire de tout c'est que
je suis sûr que vous avez raison
maintenant je suis sûr que vous avez
raison j'ai dit je suis sûr qu'à fait de
l'appliquer je suis sûr que vous avez
raison je vous demande simplement si si
j'aurai la force d'appliquer tout ce que
vous dites c'est pas une question de
force parce que on s'imagine faut
renoncer à tous notamment les glaces à
la framboise non mais en fait si quelque
chose était vraiment faisait vraiment du
bien ça serait complètement absurde il
en c1 mais on est un peu comme un
trekkeur qui a un sac à dos et il
s'aperçoit moment donné car la moitié
c'est des provisions l'autre moitié des
cailloux mais un décideur s'alléger un
petit peu il ya des choses qui sont pas
nécessaires pour avoir une véritable
satisfaction dans l'existant ouais en
lisant votre bouquin j'ai compris plein
de trucs mais bon vous êtes par exemple
beaucoup de nos pensées perturbatrice
ces fameuses toxines mentale dont vous
parlez sont dus à l'ego
effectivement vous dit pas ce manque pas
demain trois semaines trois semaines
après un coup de poing on n'a plus mal
mais c'est notre ego qui est meurtri là
et si vous voulez le sentiment très
puissant de l'importance de soi c'est
comme une cible alors toutes les flèches
la jalousie et le dépit l'envi ce ils
vont ils vont taper là dessus a à coeur
joie
évidemment si vous avez plus de liberté
mais quelqu'un qui vous dit quelque
chose que pas très gentil c'est un peu
comme un écho ainsi vous même vous d'une
falaise espèce d'imbécile 1
ça vous fait rigoler dans ça revient
pourquoi parce que ça touche pas votre
ego c'est vous qui l'avez dit mais si
c'est qu'arnaud qui dit tout de suite là
vous êtes comme un petit coq l'a
enflammée et vous supportez pas il faut
arrêter à tout prix de se protéger de
satisfaire son égo laurent oui mais ça
fait des années que je n'écoute que toi
il faut pas se laisser aline et par le
désir aussi vous dites on veut faire un
truc puis un autre puis encore un autre
âge avancé et les seules choses qui
viennent réfréner ce désir c'est l'échec
et la fatigue mais sinon on s'arrête
jamais
c'est à dire qu'il faut pas confondre le
désir l'aspiration a le désir c'est
vraiment ça se transforme souvent en une
soif c'est un peu comme de l'eau salée
le plus on en boit un journal soit donc
on n'est jamais vraiment satisfait
l'aspiration c'est le désir justement de
devenir un meilleur être humain de
contribuer un peu aux biens d'autrui de
protéger l'environnement ça c'est
quelque chose qui vous qui bouge
l'esprit mais qu'en même temps un aspect
constructeur sa part un aspect où chaque
fois on et j'arrive jamais a
complètement satisfaire et ça recommence
donc là il ya un aspect blessure qui est
un peu frustrant par disque une
satisfaction profonde qui naît de
l'accomplissement d'une tâche
c'est quelque chose au contraire qui
comme un paysan qui a bien semer son
champ ça se passera pas aussi bien
qu'ils pensent y aura de la grêle mais
lui il n'a pas de regret il certaine
paix en lui-même le désir sexuel vous en
pensez-quoi mathieu savez c'est un des
dix années plus puissant puisqu'il met
en fait en en
on est comme élément la fois le le
touche il
l'odorat donc tous les cinq sens donc
c'est certain que du point de vue des
sensations c'est certainement le plus
puissant et donc c'est aussi celui qui
sait ancien tâche est peut-être vécu de
façon extrêmement pleine mais qui en
même temps est celui qu'il suscite le
plus de nos tourmenté puisque aussi bien
les cinq sens sont impliqués et donc
forcément
alors voilà il faut savoir trop quand
même mieux je trouve mais on peut se
débarrasser de la haine il faut se
débarrasser de la jalousie s'affranchir
des sentiments et des non pas du tout
juste là pour contraire les sentiments
qui vous rendent esclaves la jalousie
serge la plus stupide au monde on est
jaloux du bonheur des autres pas de leur
malheur en fait si on avait un tout
petit peu de désir que ce soit heureux
on devrait se réjouir c'est le son ça
fait savoir faire déjà ça vous apporte
rien sa mine votre tranquillité
intérieure ya strictement aucun avantage
à la jalousie si on y réfléchit bien
c'est le sentiment le plus absurde
qu'ils soient situés touchés par ce
qu'il dit non charles pasqua là il n'y a
pas davantage de mauvais sentiments mais
tout le monde sait que c'est des bons
des mauvais sentiments au laus s bat
souvent et c'était pli on est un peu
comme un rouleau de papier qui a été
très longtemps roulé sur lui même alors
on essaie de l'aplatir il se roule tout
de suite on a des penchants des
habitudes et si on veut essayer de
trouver un peu de quiétude faut
justement défaire sa petit à petit pour
acquérir une vraie liberté intérieure
c'est très drôle parce qu'en occident on
se dit finalement être libre c'est à
tout ce qui vous passe par la tête
ouais alors qu'en fait on est l'esclave
toutes les pensées qui vous passe par la
tête
prenez jean delas marin un être libre
c'est parler c'est son bateau partir à
la dérive selon les vents les courants
être libre c'est prendre la barre et
voguer intéressant qu'on a choisi donc
une vraie liberté c'est d'être sur une
certaine maîtrise choisir son chemin si
terrible d'entendre des choses vraies
comme ça c'est tellement rare dont on
parlait du temps aussi vous dites il
faut savoir mieux profiter du temps et
vous citer cette phrase de sénèque
ce n'est pas que nous disposons de peu
de temps c'est plutôt que nous en
perdrons beaucoup c'est vrai s'ils
voulaient le temps mais l'on en fait oui
la vie est longue mais justement elle
est longue
être viendra quand même assez rapidement
à sa fin et donc si on se disait on voit
bien des gens qui apprennent brusquement
qu'ils ont une maladie terminale qu'ils
ont disons un an à vivre y en a qui sont
complètement effondrés il y en a
beaucoup qui vous diront que cette année
était la plus riche la plus dense parce
que chaque instant avait son poids au
lieu d'être du temps de paco dit ça
devenait de l'or parce que chaque chose
avait sa valeur donc le passage du temps
c'est très important il faut pas ça soit
un film sans images qui passent dans un
projecteur sans lampe et puis on
s'aperçoit à la fin que la vie est
passée et que finalement on n'a pas
réussi à accomplir quelque chose vous
expliquer très bien est ce que c'est
parce que vous êtes un occidental qui
est passé à l'est où est ce que les
maîtres que vous avez rencontrées vous
expliquer les choses d'une façon aussi
claire quand vous les avez connus
maintenant seulement il m'expliquer les
choses de façon claire mesquer plus
extraordinaire encore c'est l'exemple
vivant
si vous voulez je crois que beaucoup de
personne en occident en prenez bien le
dalaï lama mais moins trois étaient des
ermites que qui n'ont pas l'air ne sont
pas très connus en occident bien sur
presque tout le monde qui a eu
l'occasion de passer de 5 10 minutes
avec des lamas il ya quelque chose qui
se passe que brusquement fait venir à la
surface le meilleur de soi même donc je
crois que l'exemple vivant finalement
c'est ce qui est plus puissant vous êtes
heureux oui bon bien sûr c'est pas je
dis pas ça avec vanité simplement je
n'ai pas toujours été c'est pour ça que
c'est intéressant si j'étais tombé dans
la potion magique du bonheur voulait
quand j'étais que j'avais 18 ans j'étais
étudiant j'ai j'avais l'idée qu'il ya un
potentiel dans la vie qu'on pouvait
actualisé méchet pas trop le mot bonheur
n'est pas beaucoup de sens mais je crois
qu'en comprenant les composantes du
bonheur les conditions qu'il favorise
celle qui le mine et le bonheur je
dirais plutôt bien être et peu à peu on
s'aperçoit effectivement qu'il ya
quelque chose qu'on peut cultiver qui
peut s'épanouir
donc dans ce sens j'ai fait quelques pas
et pour moi je suis très heureux de sa
crise temps qui passe or vous êtes
chasse tenons tant que moine ben oui
c'était des conditions de la vie
monastique mais vous savez tout ça c'est
très relatif je dire parce que ce n'est
pas tourmenté par justement le désirent
à ce moment là jeudi elle ça ne ce n'est
pas un poids un moine qui se sentiraient
pieds poings liés pour parce qu'il a
interdiction de tout faire il vaut mieux
pas qu'il soit moines et 600 contraire
comme un oiseau qui s'envole dans le
ciel
à ce moment là bas il a toul mais ça a
été difficile pour vous au départ de
cette espèce de voeux de chasteté non
parce que ça s'est fait très
progressivement disons j'ai commencé
j'étais à la cité pasteur j'ai vu une
vie parisienne puis je commencer à vivre
dans un monastère puis dans un ermitage
j'ai vécu pas mal d'années en
d'hermitage donc là de façon dans un
village on est tout seul
et puis peu à peu j'ai trouvé j'ai
appris à vivre chaque instant d'une
façon différente
et puis à moment donné je me suis dit
bon ben j'ai changé d'habits je vais
déjà près d'un monastère
ça fait pas de grande différence j
[Musique]
vraiment envie d'aller au bout d'abord
away alors maintenant on va recevoir
quelqu'un qui a encore plus besoin de
vous que moi
[Musique]
on
merci sylvain laurens
[Musique]
sylvain laurens bonsoir grande à la
bataille bataille
ça va j'aurai besoin de monsieur mouais
je suis comme vous je fais exactement le
contraire de ce qu'ils prêchent c'est
mal maillot je regrette je n'étais pas
vous peut pas aller contre ma nature
vous savez que si si si quand votre
nature autre force sa nature les pour sa
nature véritable secte avait eu toujours
des phrases très très fort et donne à
réfléchir
monsieur ça me fait plaisir mathieu
c'est une pierre de bons clients mathieu
ça devient contre
revenir dans l'émission quand tu veux
quand vous voulez voilà et on a passé un
coup de fil on s'en va chercher un jeu
dur à lhassa si vous pouviez à être là
toutes les semaines pour apporter un peu
traîné sans son bateau avait un portable
le ch l'avait senti dans les maliens n'y
a pas de portable voilà la différence
comment cela silvana il n'a pas de
portable déjà première différence sur
moi je m'affale ya beaucoup de boulot
venant des emails à des emails des
emails alors sylvain laurens nous aussi
les coulisses de la galerie arts de
l'espace cardin vous êtes une figure de
la de la jet set
devenue récurrente dans des émissions
télé qui lui sont consacrés et vous
publié chez flammarion un livre
s'appelle à nous deux paris où vous
racontez vos deux passions l'art et
pierre cardin que vous voulez absolument
épouse et oui on peut toujours rêver
oui n'est ce pas ça n'est pas interdit
c'est bon pour le monde ces bonbons le
mangement l'accompagnateur après après
la lecture de ce livre donc évidemment
je vous conseille encore une fois de
dire celui de mathieu parce que que dgo
dans votre livre que dgo que de plaisir
que de désir que deux poisons mentaux
silvana bon alors vous trouvez que j'ai
beaucoup dé bon roi ça soit c'est un
docteur c'est très beau excitement de à
mathieu vous allez dire son bouquin
faites moi plaisir de lire son livre
mais si c'est pour vous faire plaisir
c'est rire qu'on me l'offre tout ce dont
vous loupé dans la finition vous l'offre
évidemment puisque vous croyez c'est un
roman
en cause un certain nombre de choses
chez vous où silvana alesi cher thierry
commencé j'avais votre victime
consentante associés vous prends les
choses bien alors vous raconter votre
vie dans ce bouquin effectivement dans
la vie parce que j'ai pas tout dire a
dit pas ça personne ne l'a achetée vous
dire que vous avez tout dit ah merde
alors si vous êtes né à tunis votre nom
de jeune fille sait quoi en faire
silvana calvi non je suis d'origine
italienne il y avait des italiens en
tunisie avait une colonie d'ariel
induisent et je faisais partie de cette
colonie alors silvana à cause de silvana
mangano voilà vous savez que ce soit en
avait lollobrigida jean marie c'est ma
copine de la jet set évidemment c'est la
copine de l'autre là alors finalement
donné bien ça non c'était des vrais ses
bijoux
écoutez il ya beaucoup de callas dans la
finance je te parle pas de caractère
religieux
alors dès l'âge de 9 ans voulait épouser
pierre cardin et ensuite j'étais fasciné
par rastignac dès que vous commencez à
l'ird et à signer par à ceignac
oui désir de rien a beaucoup qui sont
fascinés par rastignac vous à dire
quelqu'un qui sort d'un milieu modeste
inscrire mon cas et qui se dit que
finalement c'est tellement mieux de
manger du caviar tous les jours et de
porter des robes sublissime et de passer
des vacances dans des endroits de
siliana
si vous saviez que vous êtes à côté du
bonheur à vous croyez jamais
complètement
alors j'ai pensé 50 ans de ma vie à
faire des conneries être à côté du
bonheur j'y suis parti en 72 il était
moins contenue nous on est toujours là
silvana bien sûr vous avez les mêmes
groupes que moi oui oui les jolies robes
bien donc à 15 ans vous rencontré ben le
peintre ben vous découvrez la
performance donc très jeune à 16 ans
vous rencontrer monsieur lawrence
lorraine s'est pas calvino vous mariez
vous arrivez à paris et vous êtes une
des premières élèves marié parce qu'à
l'époque c'était très très rare c'était
les années post soixante huitarde donc
le directeur était déjà très 68 eur et
il m'a dit écoute ta qu'a faire passer
ton mari pour ton frère étudierait la
personne et à ceux de la sugar à 19 ans
vous avez de bach
oui c'est un peu tard non ça va et à 22
ans votre première fille amandine oui
aussi ma licence en lettres modernes
aussi plus mais bien sûr voilà je ne
suis pas la peine qu'on pense je suis
licencié de l'université incurable
personnellement m'enfin bon alors votre
votre mariage bat de l aile très
rapidement pourquoi ça se passait mal
est monsieur lawrence
non c'est pas ça mais vous savez les
hommes à vous les connaissez - bien que
les femmes
ah oui ah oui c'est vrai donc leurs
voeux de mariage votre mariage bas de
laine non sérieusement qu'est ce qui
s'est passé mais seulement j'étais
mariée avec un jeune loup qui ne
pensaient qu'à sa profession alors il
partait le matin est revenu le soir on
l'a on avait l'impression qu'il avait
été bloquée toute la machine dans toute
la journée dans la machine à laver à
l'essorage ça fait que je pouvais pas en
faire grand chose le soir aussi qu'en
tire après finalement j'ai vécu ma vie
tout seul vous tomber amoureuse de
maître cornette de saint cyr bel homme
ah ouais très sexy très malheureusement
je n'étais pas la seule à tomber
amoureuse de m d'ailleurs c'est souvent
voir des mages vous allez voir le match
béline c'est qu'ici je suis assez âgé
pour savoir qui c'est oui le match v
line qui vous promet quoi la gloire
oui oui oui il me dit tout de suite que
je vais avoir une galerie rue du
faubourg saint-honoré et que je vais
être très célèbre d'ailleurs c'est pour
ça que je suis ici aujourd'hui on en
parle en 82 dont première galerie
ensuite vous rencontrer pierre cardin
pour vous si une sorte d'apothéose de
rencontrer pierre cardin c'était mon
idole depuis toujours et puis
bon père car demain c'est pierre cardin
je ne sais pas ce qu'il a mais cet homme
a une part de charisme exceptionnel une
perte de magnétisme et il dégage voilà
depuis lors il a dégagé et j'étais sous
son charme et je le suis toujours je le
serai tout jusqu'à la fin de ma vie
certainement petit intermède aux usa
avec un producteur
c'était bien la vie hollywoodienne et
tout mais finalement je préférais la
france à vrai dire et les français
ensuite vous revenez vous re fréquenté
cornette de saint cyr vous présentez
combat césar arman enfin tous les
peintres qui compte
vous devenez mais la maîtresse d'un
milliardaire lequel john boehner ah oui
celui-là je l'avais oublié c'est vrai
oui oui c'est vrai saison de bouquins
pourquoi ça va pas marcher avec lui
parce que ça va marcher avec aucun homme
y en avait qu'un seul qui finalement les
vallées bien plus que tout c'est pire
car voilà voilà
c'est pire qu'un bref on en remet
toujours que c'est impossible avec les
regards d'un vous avez raté votre vie
simplement parce que vous aviez
amoureuse simplement parce que pierre
cardin
c'est pas impossible avec kar kar d'un
mois je travaille quand même avec paire
cardin je fais partie de sa maison puis
j'ai bon espoir de terminer mon dans le
mariage performance toujours l'épousé ou
à la fin du lit je m'appelle silvana
cardin oui c'est mieux que silva la
lorraine c'est ce qu'on pensait est ce
que je trouve bien c'est que ça nous
ramène en fait à fanfan la tulipe et à
gina lollobrigida parce que finalement
c'est une histoire de prédiction way qui
va finir par se réaliser
c'est un divertissement c'est tout est
quelque chose de très léger comme robin
de superficiel et les
et voilà et qui en vol et toi tu es
comme ça charles stade et à des désirs
tas d ambition dans la vie non moi aussi
j'ai désiré les ambitions et c'est quoi
s'en va c'est pas tant la mort est mon
rêve c'est de faire vivre vingt
vingt-cinq personnes autour de moi
voilà c'est tout ce qui nous intéresse
que au moins six pas mon billet il y en
a qui puisse avoir le sourire
c'était bien bon bien alors là après
vous commencez à devenir célèbre vous
rencontrer christophe dechavanne vous
vous occupez de la rubrique artistique
dans coucou ou irie 10-q lise l'art
conceptuel tous les jours et vient de
lancer vous participez à cette visite
nous avons des rencontres de sharm al
houssi dans les banlieues on connaît
l'art conceptuel aujourd'hui c'est grâce
à moi
et grâce à dechavanne
contre l'art conceptuel dès lors
personne n'a rien contre l'art
conceptuel en tous les cas pas ce que je
pense et que le ridiculiser à sept
heures du soir à la télé c'est pas
assumer un service qu'on puisse curan et
d'utiliser leurs contemporains toute
façon dès qu'on se met à parler verre
contemporain ça n'intéresse personne
alors autant trouver un billet vous avez
vous une émission d'art contemporain la
télé vous pas d'émissions sur le
rock'n'roll alors quand son bord donc
c'était une voie pour en parler c'est
tout
vient ensuite vous occuper de la galerie
cardin vous devenez un personnage en là
c'est encore une autre époque vous
devenez un personnage de télé là espèce
de symboles de la jet set
un rôle de composition de ce que vous
dites mais c'est ce que je dis mais
c'est vrai vous le savez bien vous avez
été longtemps la star de zone interdite
et et vous dit d'ailleurs que l'émission
était bidonné en fait bien pourquoi
biden darragi louit que c'était un
personnage de composition
vous dites bien que l'émission est
débité ça n'avait rien à voir avec m6
c'est à dire que moi je trouve que j'ai
pris le parti de décrypter un peu ce
milieu et donc de souligner au marqueur
certaines aberrations de certains
personnages de ce milieu j'ai quatre
caricaturise et personnages c'était ma
responsabilité personnelle c'est moi qui
suis allé devant les caméras et qui
jouer ce rôle
on n'a pas écrit un rôle à l'avancé
d'accord donc c'était pas bidonné
c'était dû parfaitement vrai bah vous
avez poussé le vice jusqu'à aller à
venise avec car cardin et vous a dit
qu'il était amoureux s'étaient pas
bidonné s'cusez moi beaucoup cardin
c'est pas le genre à rentrer dans mon
film et à jouer
il était vraiment dans votre film car il
était vraiment dans mon film
quand on dit qu'il est amoureux de vous
à venise vous y croyez il n'a pas dit
qu'il était amoureux de moi à venise
mais il à de tendres sentiments
certainement pour moi et ils sont tout à
fait partagé et après tout pourquoi le
pourquoi croire enfin ne pas croire
qu'on puisse cm ça vous est dubitatif
non mais est ce qu'on pourra y
sérieusement que vous allez devenir
mannequin d'un jour je l'espère de tout
coeur
et après tout ce mariage n'est pas n'est
pas une aberration c'est une performance
artistique
on peut quand même comprendre que c'est
la consécration de 30 ans d'activités
artistiques allié à 10 ans d'activité
médiatique
ce qui fait que finalement on rentre
dans une performance d'ailleurs où vous
êtes invités puisque tous les gens qui
m'ont aidé et vous en avez vous avez été
un de ceux là seraient invités à mon
mariage performance donc oui j'y crois
mais transformer le mariage quelque
chose de sacré en une performance c'est
pas un blasphème est quelque chose de
sacré qu'est ce que ça veut dire
un mariage performance est pas ça crée
une performance n'est pas sacré c'est de
l'art non on n'aimait pas l'avouer j'ai
compris hein
bien mathieu sérieusement quel est votre
votre jugement est un pas de juger qui
que ce soit mais simplement cette deux
façons d'aborder le mellah sur la robe
comme m je crois que toute personne n'y
a personne qui se lève le matin je dise
en plus sage être malheureux toute la
journée
ouais d'une façon directe ou indirecte
consciente ou inconsciente à droite ou
maladroites on aspire tous à une
certaine façon à trouver une certaine
satisfaction alors est-ce qu
effectivement on la cherche au bon
endroit c'est toute la question
ça
[Musique]
et maintenant passer à tout le monde en
rêve
[Musique]
adel
ban
et dans tout le monde en rêve
j'accueille le retour de cameron est là
messieurs
[Musique]
bonsoir ces gamins bonsoir à toutes et à
tous alors quand même nous a énormément
plu lors de sa première visite et c'est
tout le monde en rêve
on donne leur chance à de nouveaux
talents mon cher nicolas et comme on l'a
adoré la première fois qu'il est venu on
lui a demandé avec catherine barma de
revenir voilà donc ce qu'on va faire on
va faire un tour de cartoon est d'accord
ouais donc aussi à 52 cartes différentes
lois parler anglais ou pas alors en cas
les algériens pendant que les jeux fait
passer les cartes existent qu'on voulait
au stop
on a certes s'il vous plaît merci ouvert
à regarder pareil pour vous madame s'il
vous plaît vous dit qu'on voulait à
noisiel vous ne vous
j'aimerais bien être madame d'accord
très bien regarder à chaque parent sida
vraiment très la caméra pour les deux
cartes tapas prix des rouges bien car
ils servent ils ont eu très bien mais
voilà pour cacher les cachets résident
n'a rien voulu engager line up
voilà la première cour jarre montre à la
caméra voilà d'accord on l'a longtemps
silvana vous donnez votre carte à l'abbé
raymond là donc c'est très sain pour
trouver la première cape
ce qu'on fait tout simplement ou encore
des doigts et la wiz une carte apparaît
de 10 de coeur ouais c'est bien la
première
merci là
fort encore pour la seconde c'est un
tout petit peu plus difficile donc 52 kg
vraiment tout tout tout tout différente
s'il faut jamais faire qu'on fait un
tour de magie
ces données le jeu tartam et angers un
arabe c'est pourquoi ça m'est arrivé
grâce à dieu donc ce qu'on va faire
surtout surtout ne jamais manger vous
savez pourquoi car un jour j'ai donné
jeudi certains arabes est ce qu il a
fait on avait fait un pari juste avant
et après les cartulaires mélanger face à
face en bas face à face en bas j'en ai
vu des mélanges mais comme celui là
j'avais donc vraiment aidé car dans tous
les sens
donc vraiment cette façon aux faces en
bas pour retrouver là car on est pas
dans la merde nous déclare nassau façon
va sauf que sauf que ce qu'ils savaient
pas c'est que ça faisait plus plus de
dix ans que je suis là magie et
simplement tout juste ça répare croire
mais tout le théâtre devient un endroit
sauf une tartine seul le valais trop là
on va essayer de faire encore plus fort
encore plus fort qu'on va faire s'il
vous plaît précigné la tarte une belle
signature ici voilà très bien merci bien
donc allez inutile rosé gaulle
donc d'accord mathieu du docteur signalé
unique cette carte ce qu'on va faire on
va juste en de petits verres net le 10
nov
signé voilà et s'ils valent picon vallin
le picard est très bien je peux avoir
tenu ces l'intrigant on désire le valet
de pique très nettement de ses rangs
deux clients 4 et 6 le joker signé le
d'accord d'accord tout doucement
s'il vous plaît à faire fermer les
petites mines tout doucement voile est
ce qu'on fera faire justice à l'air à
vue ouais elle en fait claque on avait
desserré le valet de pique des colères
invalides puis quiz ira boire est tout
doucement on regarde les la vieillesse
on a effectivement les 10 de turquie
merci merci bien
merci bien outils confidences série en
réalité ce tour là quelqu'un darwin qui
nous l'expliqué marché atwater précis
mais non non non grâce à dieu je connais
pas au 6 mars et encore merci
conakry et du salon avant de placer de
la neige nous libérer et matthieu ricard
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été avec
nous
[Musique]
on a beaucoup à apprendre de lui un taux
compris lui un avis ouais bien
alors maintenant passe au blind test
[Musique]
et pour le blind test j'accueille dj
kost bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir donc vous
connaissez le principe du blind test
nicolas baverez vous regardez l'émission
toutes les semaines jusqu'à la fin j'en
suis sûr sinon vous ne craignez pas des
livres si bien et donc je veux
l'interprète c'est tout c'est très
simple kamel attention tu es prêt je
suis prêt à voir si tu es aussi magique
au blind test qu'avec des cartes
voilà c'est la chance aux autres
attention dès que vous êtes prêt dj koze
c'est parti on y va on écoute bêtise
c'est charles bien trouvé
[Musique]
attention numéro 2
mais
attention attention dj cost à bas
ouais
[Applaudissements]
m
l'enquêté en solo
non
et
attention dj kost
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention la dj koze amiguet ouais
[Musique]
sienne a ajouté
dj kost diana ross
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
six mois
oh
je n'ai pas aidé la presse ne pas avoir
un peu de bardot va rentrer en service
et qui pique un puits dit tiens feliz il
ya un super méga banques
attention attention vici cost
[Musique]
vous
[Applaudissements]
c'est tout
robert allenby
bien bien bien bien jeune quand vous
traversez qu'on allait le dire à une
seconde motion pour les écoute sa femme
bouge toi prochain dire attention
messieurs le prochain soit sympa dj kost
voyage
[Musique]
attention l'abus pour faire la tension
dj kost garage
oui
[Applaudissements]
non
à attention celui qui gagne ou celle qui
gagne aura gagné le super banco dans
corp a gagné le blind test voilà c'est
injuste je sais si bon jour attention dj
kost
non
merci dj kost merci beaucoup pour ce
blind test donc ben voilà c'est lui qui
a gagné c'est toi qui a gagné voilà c
[Applaudissements]
la mère je t'emmerde
et je t'emmerde tous les quais tous les
week-ends sous les ponts je reste
concret direct c'est la guerre gelée
batch ou celui qui sait 1
tomei la vérité sur toi moi je la palais
sous lesquelles tous les mois les belges
ou les conjoints est contré
direct c'est la guerre tous les braves
gens c'est le 10ème
j'étais sur toi moi je connais tu près
du mas pour qu'il comprenne grande
saucisse talent si bienne se faisait
dans ses chansons et sketches et
pourtant ils m'ont dit que des piles l
inclusion l'emballage est pas le concret
skis gillotte danton qualité chétif que
chez gharbi starter jetant divers jetés
en mer onéreuse
l'amicale la tronçonneuse avant de
donner des leçons regarde avec qui tu as
fait retomber si et puis seulement avait
baissé son froc pour en arriver là et
ouais c'est vrai ce jour là tu en avais
pas ici avec des styles malheureusement
je coupe du bois j'temmerde 12 et pas un
cerveau années qui viennent sa pole avec
l'autre fera chaud georges place une
spéciale pourquoi le japon car tu as toi
tu l'a encore rappelé à l'envers du
décor elle compte du racisme sept trains
grèce qui regroupe en même temps qu'une
temps maire rappelle paul ii
mélancolique
et voir aller
c'était tout moment pas l'ombre d'une
nation
[Musique]
le temps du monde ni qu'elle était allée
béatrice dalle isabelle huppert et ap 08
nos frites sida exposition sculpture à
l'hôtel de la main
10 octobre au 4 janvier mais là
messieurs jack lang une école élitaire
pour tous si je gagne en folio aïcha el
wafi la bande
ça oui son fils mc jean gabin l'album
s'appelle navy nicolas baverez la france
qui change c'est oublié je sais faire je
me voyais à la vie de château
la vendetta française ça sort chez albin
michel jeu 9 octobre
matthieu ricard les loyers pour le
bonheur chez nil éditions
bon ben alors est à nous de paris j'ai
de la marion ficelles
l'album s'appelle get rich or die tryin
à tout le monde au rex et kamel n'est
pas là et dj kost l'album s'appelle
explosive
merci dj koze ainsi donc nous voilà
concert de soutien au peuple tibétain
tibet libre le mardi 14 octobre à 19h30
au zénith de paris les pays
serviront à financer des projets
humanitaires pour venir en aide aux
tibétains voilà au revoir j'étais
souvent tard rendez-vous les genevois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
c